peu
[Musique]
très
oui
mes gosses tello szabados noches
bienvenue sur le plateau de tout moment
par l'émission pas comme les autres vous
connaissez le principe tout le monde en
parle alors tout le monde en parle
vous connaissez ce type voici thierry
lhermitte
tout le monde le motoriste écran soir
thierry lhermitte alors c'est la
première fois que vous venez à tout le
monde en parle on est ravi surtout que
c'est l'émission numéro 69 et je pense
que toutes nos téléspectatrices
apprécieront quand même le geste quand
même on n'a pas envie que n'importe qui
tu sais que c'est cela oui ça va vous
connaissez les missions en les bouches
pendant les guignols j'ai entendu pas
d'accord quand ça va être la promo de
votre film c
et si vraiment vous fait des discours
mais vous ce palais pas de danger mais
si des fois on faisait l'histoire dont
il est compliqué c'est ça c'est les gens
les gens font ça quand il entendit move
et nicolas supporter on les comprend
c'est pas mal à ces salles
j'avais donc c'est un public
complètement instrumentalisé et
entièrement à ma dévotion et qui fait
tout ce que je veux
alors votre vrai nom votre vrai nom vous
le dites jamais votre vrai nom je dis
jamais je sais oui bah ouais c'est
e-retail serait-ce pas terrible non non
mais c'est vrai thierry lhermitte c'est
bien pourquoi dermique ben j'ai trouvé
que c'était sympa comme ça ça faisait un
peu solitaire avec un peu mais qui a
passé sa vie dans une base celle du
splendid
ouais ouais ça me met deux d'un côté un
petit peu particulier way lhermitte je
repars moi si j'avais dû prendre un
pseudo j'aurais pas pris l'air mais là
non mais je sais bien mais c'est pour ça
que j'ai jamais cherché qualifier votre
vrai nom parce que ça fait mal ce doux
lhermitte on se dit quand on s'appelle
lhermitte c'est un truc qu'on n'a pas pu
choisir c'est vrai je sais je sais une
est une erreur je pense qu'il s'est
passé thierry tu ailles madame alors
famille bourgeoise non attends ouais on
va me l'ont fait avec ça maintenant
pendant chez palm
c'est pas vrai c'est beau je sais pas
moi c'est mon vrai nom taye moreno
je voulais monter un dossier sinon ça va
être un cauchemar ça m a pris dans les
dents les machins et donc c'est vrai
c'est tout
je dis toujours la vérité parce qu'on va
faire l'interview mensonge enlève aux
cheveux pendant les jean galle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dès qu'il ya pas baffie c'est un bonheur
cette émission les débats fist au
mexique c'est insensé j'ai reçu un email
et au mexique n'ont pas lui il ya débat
fisto mais revendique des gens qui
regardent l'émission au mexique qui
bouge pendant le jingle qui axa sens et
cette histoire alors à l'époque de deux
pasteurs
vous avez des relations homosexuelles et
que gérard jugnot
ben oui il faut en faire un musée
mais c'est vrai que récemment c'est vrai
que récemment vous avez décidé de faire
un petit essai tous les deux à nouveau
ensemble
il veut pas voir mais voilà le problème
c'est qu'on veut paraît voilà c'est vrai
je pense qu'il faut rien n'est perdu
je te le dit gérard voit les caméras je
te le digère je suis encore là et je
crois je t'attendrai toute ma vie bien
thierry tail en continu dont vous avez
fait votre service militaire dans légion
étrangère
vous avez eu une aventure avec un
sergent un ancien de l'indo qui était le
fils naturel du général de gaulle ça ne
s'est pas beaucoup non effectivement ces
périodes
c'est comme notre énorme
et alors mais
quand on sait lire entre les lignes des
articles de fond celle à qui on le
comprend effectivement il était beau et
chaud il sentait bon le sable chaud
alors au début du stand hésitiez gigolo
pour payer les travaux
vous en avez souffert de ça ça vous a
humilié nom et que je ne crache pas
non monsieur j'ai souhaité vous j'ai
redouté j'ai rendu heureux croyez moi
c'est donner du bonheur
vous êtes un film porno le propos de
premier film en fait c'est un film porno
avec brigitte lahaie
vous avez une aventure de plusieurs mois
avec elle et elle dit vous quand elle
parle de vous elle dit il aurait pu être
un superbe reco siffredi là je peux pas
répondre à cette question des changes
avait déchaîné les foules mais là je ne
peux même pas nombreux merci brigitte
votre boîte échangiste préféré à paris
en ce moment c'est quoi c'est pas tout à
fait mathieu doby thérèse pas d'accord
et je connais alors est la mienne prend
comment votre aventure avec claire keim
là pendant le tournage du film le roman
de lulu
voilà une habitude énorme
oui c'est bien cette fois méchanceté
quand même temps vous êtes ensemble ces
premiers chalets 25 ou éventuelle oui
oui ces habitués bien sûr y'a pas de
problème
non non non au camp est claire elle
supporte que vous aviez quand même de
temps en temps la maison elle si c'est
plus dur pour elle nous dimanche en
musique cet objectif est obligé d'aller
j'avais envie d'aller voir les enfants
et tout aussi poliment dit fièrement
thierry taille vous êtes un grand ami de
jean marie le pen n'hésite pas désolé un
petit peu par la disparition du front
national du paysage politique français
sont ils se sont gâchées vraiment la
libye
ils ont déconné est vrai quand on a des
cantons et des beaux amis comme ça ça se
brouiller pour une histoire de cul c'est
tombé je savais que ça nous inquiète le
plus riche en fait des anciens du
splendid vous investissez beaucoup dans
les airs aux senteurs dans le nord de
l'europe et vous avez une spécialité
c'est la russe fait venir des camions
grues sont fades et les russes des
slovènes ça marche il est spécialisé
dans le pays de l'est ce bout j'avais
des amis qui bêtement on a mis en cause
la vie qui vient de se faire incarcérer
mais très bêtement mais ils pourront
fournissait c'était sympa mais qu'est ce
qu'elles ont le plus les filles de l'est
pourquoi voulez vous le faites venir par
camion par wagons entiers sont sincères
halsouet sont si c'est ça elle compte
pas alors déclaré je voudrais mourir
comme elvis presley bourré de
tranquillisants bourré de sucre est en
train de sauter des lolitas vous
maintenez ça oui oui c'est une sorte
d'apothéose c'est vrai que devant votre
place vous essayer de chanter comme
elvis et tout ça c'est que pour moi est
bon et les russes et les lolitas
le guerrier scotto et claire keim pas
vous citez j'accueille maintenant pour
sa première télévision en france n'ont
ni kambale
naomi bonsoir bonsoir monsieur alors je
vous dis je vous regarde dans les yeux
parce que vous avez dit que s'il y en a
mais pas capable de vous regarder dans
les yeux c'est pas la peine qu'ils vous
regardent
c'est tout à fait vrai je vous regarde
dans les yeux comme ça voilà alors d'air
quand on vous regarde on s'aperçoit que
vous êtes extrêmement jolie et que votre
réputation n'est pas usurpée
alors andré leon talley que moi je me
permettrai pas de parler de votre
physique évidemment mais andre leon
talley qui est un grand journaliste de
mode américain qui a longtemps travaillé
au vogue us a dit en parlant de vous
naomi cambell un fessier si haut si
stable si ferme qu'on pourrait poser une
flûte de champagne dessus est utilisé
comme table à cocktail
essayons ce soit est ce qu'on peut nous
apporter du champagne
[Applaudissements]
et donatella versace a dit de vous vous
étiez la marilyn monroe noir je ne pense
pas mais c'est vraiment très gentil de
dire ça de moi mais j'aime beaucoup ma
rétine
je l'aimé beaucoup vous la trouvez
comment j'allais très belle rebelle est
intimidé aussi elle mais à moi aussi
mais de cela et où m si vous savez c'est
un petit peu ma personnalité
côté timide un côté qui n'est pas et
quand on en public vous pas c'est qu'à
chaque fois que je suis vieux par
exemple dans les coulisses et que je
vais commencer un show je ne suis pas
nerveuse et ici je suis nerveuse je
pense que c'est bien de ne pas être trop
sûr de soi même parce que vous donnerez
pas le meilleur de vous même
donc j'ai c'est effectivement de donner
le meilleur de moi même et ça veut dire
d'être un peu nerveux alors votre beauté
est dû à des origines très mais les 12es
du sang chinois du sang noir du sang
semblant aussi donc ma grand mère elle
sa famille avant qu'elle ne se marier à
mon grand père et mon grand mon
arrière-grand-père directement les
chinois c'est un beau mélange et
pourtant alors quand vous étiez à
l'école à l'école d'art à stoke well vos
camarades vous appelez sac d'os alors ça
a changé quand même les sacs d'os avait
les enfants peuvent être très méchants
les uns avec les autres
alors l'époque j'ai commencé par faire
de la danse poussé par votre mère qui
voulait vous soyez une star
non non non elle a sacrifié ses
inspirations en ma faveur mais quand
j'avais 13 ans je lui ai déjà dit à
l'époque je voulais passer à trois ans
j'étais déjà en mesure de dire ce que je
vous
mais absolument elle ne pouvait pas
m'obliger à le devenir il fallait que je
le sentais c'était le cas vous avez ça
en commun avec jeanne moreau et xavier
un bon caractère déjà très affirmée très
jeune je descends comme alors à l'époque
vous pensiez pas devenir mannequin
jusqu'à ce que quelqu'un vous vous
découvre vous avez été découvertes
comment c'est un quartier enfin sur ie
covent garden à londres et j'avais 14
ans et c'était après l'école je me
baladais cette dame a été vue lui c'est
une ex mannequin elle m'a dit j'ai une
agence est-ce que vous venir me voir il
y avait ces filles blondes magnifique
avec des cheveux longs et je me disais
moi et à ma mère m'a dit d'accord mais
au débit elle voulait m'interdire elle
disait je ne veux pas que tu fasses la
l2 en gelée rappelé l' matinée mais je
me souviens de vous et voilà on est c
est à 16 ans naomi campbell devient
mannequin
vous êtes le premier mannequin noir à
avoir fait la couverture de vogue
évidemment iv iman bowie et grace jones
qui avait ouvert la voie
vous avez été la première à faire la
couverture de vogue et après d'ailleurs
la première à faire la couverture de
time magazine
dix ans dix ans après vous pensez que ça
a évolué vous pensez que c'est plus
facile
dix ans après pour des filles noires de
faire des couvertures de magazines en
amérique où c'est toujours pareil c'est
pire qu'avant enquête crasnault quoi je
pense que c'est pire si vous regardez
les magazines pendant que certains mais
vous pouvez peut-être deux et c'est
peut-être parce que je m'entraîne avec
derrière des filets avec une personne
maintenant j'ai vu défiler mais je
savais remords j'en ai vu qu ça et je
pense que c'est vraiment très triste
parce que ça montre que les gens sont
très étroits d'esprit correct ça va pas
vers le mieux alors vous avez connu un
énorme succès vous allez gagner en 1998
15 millions de francs quand vous dites
vous gagner beaucoup d'argent vous dit
d'abord parce que je suis pas mannequin
comme les autres et deuxièmement il
m'arrive de faire des choses
gratuitement c'est vrai alors elton john
dit en parlant de vous quand on voit
naomi campbell sur un podium
on réalise qu'elle mérite vraiment
chaque centime qu'elle gagne
[Musique]
voilà
m
mme amélie
[Musique]
je
non
[Musique]
m
nous à dire
[Musique]
m
c
[Musique]
énorme erreur
mais quand même
alors m'a remis au moment de tout ce
grand succès que vous avez eue
vous aviez des moments un peu dit un peu
difficile vous étiez un peu
incontrôlable à l'époque non au chef des
urgences savez j'avais 15 ans il était
en fait en train de mûrir de grandir
devant les publics je faisais tout mais
avant tout donc c'est déjà difficile de
faire des erreurs en tant qu'adolescente
ensuite il fallait le faire devant tout
le monde dans quel but c'est vraiment
spécial
pas facile mais on apprend de ses
erreurs ouais c'est vrai en plus dans le
métier quand on dit non une fois ci un
photographe vous photographiez vous
voulez pas ou si on vous met un micro
comme ça sous le nez voulait pas
répondre vous traitent tout de suite de
garde c'est vrai que c'est difficile de
se protéger contre cette agression des
médias si vous dites non vous êtes une
garce c'est ridicule parce que il faut
enfin d'analystes qui vous reste quelque
chose vous avez été victime de ça vous
de cette espèce de l'agression des
médias comme été victime moi j'avais
fait le choix c'était une fois dans une
rue de rome
j'étais avec
un homme que je connaissais depuis peu
et on intéressait particulièrement les
paparazzi comme on les appelait et on
n'arrêtait pas de nous suivre un jour
j'en ai marre je dis on s'arrête et on
fait les photos ils ont pris les photos
après ça les a tous les intéressés par
les intéressait plus c'est la chose qui
nous un peu voilà le gibier celle du
moment donné
youtube était scandaleuse à l'époque
quand même vous passez votre temps dans
les boîtes de nuit à boire des coups au
tout le monde se demande si vous avez
une culotte vous soumet c'était pas
facile c'est vrai nom savez si tu n'es
pas d'accord
rock'n'roll soulager les internes ont
donc qu'est ce qu'on fait quand on
n'avait rien mais on veut aller s'amuser
danser avec les copains vous savez
venant de moi ce n'est pas un reproche
parce que moi non plus je n'ai pas de
slip donc
je peux pas me créditer en même temps je
ne peux pas me compliquer bien mais
c'est vrai que l'on vous a marié un peu
comme jeanne moreau des parce que tous
les hommes qu'on vous a attribué vous
n'osez pas eu obligatoirement non mais
alors ces règles on vous a attribué
beaucoup beaucoup d'hommes il y en a
certains en tous les cas si vous avez eu
bravo parce qu'il ya vraiment de très
beaux il ya eu cette histoire de
tentative
on a parlé de tentative de suicide aux
au canada je sais j'étais vraiment en
colère j'étais ou du campagne sur les
vices est donc en train de faire cette
prise de vie et mais si vous étiez bien
mais je dis mais j'avais un virus une
gastro entérite et là je me suis dit
mais je peux pas l hôpital qu est ce que
je fais oui en fait ça aurait été dans
un pays normal vous auriez eu un médecin
qui se réduit à l'hôtel mais comme
c'était un petit peu isolé mais c'est
vrai peut-être vous avez eu cette
réputation de gars peut-être parce que
vous avez cherché à vous protéger à
construire un mur autour de vous avec
one year je pense que quand il lorsqu'on
est jeune on est un peu sur la défensive
j'étais pas défensive quand il s'agit
s'agissait de ma vie privée mais
évidemment a fait du fait de la couleur
de ma peau je me défendrai aussi et
maintenant que j'ai 30 ans je réalise
qu'il ya d'autres manières détenir ce
qu'on veut sans avoir à être aussi
désert
et j'essaye ses doigts le béton des sa
marche
j'avais marrante parce qu'elle dit
maintenant que j'ai 30 ans comme shine
avait 5 ans maintenant que j'ai 30 ans
j'ai maintenant je suis une grande fille
belle janoueix talentueux g4 du succès
c'est toujours une garce
c'est vrai on dit toujours ça défi qui
réussit ce match on dit sun madonna en
isan mariah carey ont dit ça de toutes
les filles c'est vrai vous avez raison
absolument alors maintenant évidemment
vous êtes rentrée naomi campbell dans
une époque de rédemption à 12h30 à la 30
maintenant elle a fait une thérapie une
thérapie aux usa nami a fini thérapie
pour apprendre à se contrôler elle est
rentrée maintenant dans une vraie
période de rédemption
parce que vous avez des choses dont
faisait des troubles du comportement
vous savez quand vous arrivez 28 ans et
je n'avais pas de pause entre un
comportement mais j'ai simplement elle
s'est dit qu'elle voulait pas travailler
j'ai décidé de prendre des vacances
pendant deux mois de partir et ceci n'a
rien à voir avec le mannequinat c'est
tellement éducation je voulais essayer
de découvrir des choses de ma famille
des sur tout à fait personnelle et pour
essayer de faire un peu d'introspection
il faut pouvoir partir il faut pas avoir
de téléphone il faut pas voir la
télévision il ne faut pas vendre la
distraction et c'est ce que j'ai fait et
en fait c'est une chose très simple à
faire
et c'est de s'occuper de soi même et
c'est la première fois de ma vie que
j'ai pris effectivement manqué petra et
j'essaye maintenant d'intégrer ceux ci
est dans ma vie quotidienne et pour que
pour avoir une espèce d'épée d'esprit
vous êtes allé dans une clinique aux
états unis vous étiez c'est vrai que
c'est il ya quatre par chambre
non c'était pas unique c'était en plein
désert
vous pouvez partir c'est vraiment un
choix que vous faites et il est vrai que
il y avait des personnes avec qui je
partageais la chambre elle était
merveilleuse et c'est quelque chose que
je voulais faut faire et personne ne
peut vous forcer à l'introspection
c'est une décision très forte que vous
devez prendre vous même est-ce que c'est
pas quand elles une idée de votre votre
amoureux flavio briatore vous envoyer
là-bas
pas du tout je suis allé voir flavio lui
dis-je c'est ce que je vais faire
perceuse personne qui ait pu le dire
quoi faire quelqu'un m'avait dit de le
faire je serai prêt à ce parti je ne
serai jamais rester il faut vouloir y
aller il faut dire que flavio mais à
tort est simple vous le connaissez non
non c'était le sait lui qui s'occupait
de l'écurie benetton formula
ils ont été deux fois champion du monde
avec chemin schumacher ah oui c'est
quelqu'un de très bien très bien
regardez regardez regardez mais alors
c'est vous avez choisi ou pas ok c'est
le vieux où le dollar est on admet
m'acheter l'ours mais à la non je pense
que naomi un homme de sa vie
ouais
je crois je peux vous dire en gros
pouvoir d'acheter
n'a aucune chance
maryse inside à l'intérieur on peut dire
naomi que c'est l'homme de votre vie
maintenant
flavio on peut dire ça je serais heureux
que vous soyez relation est alors je
vais vous dire une chose
il a il a 50 ans vous avez 30 ans c'est
très bien non mais que 50 ans on peut
avoir 30 ans passé tout ça il m'a tuer
la différence bien sûr voilà exactement
bas
je vous avais dit naomi cambell en
parlant des enfants si je doit tomber
enceinte je tendrais enceinte mais je
veux pas non plus faire des enfants
parce que toutes mes collègues en ce
moment sont en train de faire des
enfants
j'ai trois amis à l'heure actuelle qui
sont en simple je peux pas dire leur nom
et je me dis oh la la
vous savez je sais bien à temps pour
chaque personne qu'on sera le temps le
monde bon moment pour moi et bien voilà
je le saurai vous avez pu le temps de
faire le petit dîner parce qu'à un
moment où vous étiez ya pas longtemps
hésité à londres j'ai des petits dîners
entre amis vous dites maintenant je suis
incapable de vous donner le nom d'une
boîte de nuit à new york
vous préférez regarder la télévision est
devenue très sage c'est vrai que vous
avez pas bu une goutte d'alcool depuis
un an
oui oui quatorze mois exactement 14
et vous
vous avez toujours une petite pierre
dans votre dans votre sac
est ce que ça veut dire que vous êtes
superstitieuse jeu les thèmes
effectivement s'il y avait un chat noir
ou au site allait passer sous une
échelle aussi j'avais un petit
grattements dit que c'était la fois de
la bonne fortune envoyé oui un petit peu
quand même oui je viens alors ce ton est
pas prêt à table 1 sur harris essart et
ça tombe bien on va faire une interview
croyance en la bouche pendant le signal
[Musique]
non mes lettres métalliques something
you must not move du règne de music a
bondi à me refaire un an ne bouge pas
pendant le dinner
[Musique]
ok merci thank you alors est ce que vous
croyez à la magie noire
non non à la magie blanche
est ce que vous croyez en dieu oui oui
absolument
est ce que vous croyez à l'effet des
crèmes antirides
oui oui d'ailleurs climatique et vous
avez c'est merveilleux donc je me suis
dit bon vent bébé est ce que vous voyez
la fidélité oui je crois
vous croyez au père noël pour les
enfants oui est ce que vous croyez au
retour des spice girls
j'aime bien baby spice je trouve qu'elle
est adorable
bienvenue avec qui vous êtes disputer
quand même en poche un nom mais elle a
décidé d'avoir une discussion d'avoir
une petite bataille avec marc ménard moi
je ne disputerai jamais avec vous jamais
mais voilà qu'il arrive on sera toujours
amis je me fâche avec vous c'est quand
on veut se fâcher avec avec vous se
moquer est ce que vous croyez vous allez
passer toute votre vie avec flavio
briatore aux options j'espère bien
belinda et vous belinda est-ce que vous
avez tué l'homme de votre vie
en plus j'ai trouvé l'homme de ma vie le
bim dallas malgré mes 20 ans et demi
vous voyez j'ai loupé de magie inscrivez
sur le plateau je ne sais pas vers était
en fait moi je suis ici
il est là bas que fait-il où va-t-il
[Applaudissements]
alors venu
un triomphe romain
ouais
cad ouais bon ça va mais tu as ça marche
jamais merde j'avais plein le cul [ __ ]
tu as pourtant j'ai tout fait perdre aux
l'hôtel aime pas les chauffe face
elle est un peu grande à elle un peu
grandes oies vendent un peu un peu puis
à la bd il avait des pieds de 40 quand
même chose du 40 les choses du car et
c'est pas les chaînes du câble pression'
ans a négocié un peu et est en plus
alors c'est bien cet ennemi du drakkar
noir fait mal c est là qu huelva reçu
ces galets en partie dans cette folle
envie très de blind test il y aura
mention philippe corti
tha
oui
non
et pour aline et et arbitrer le blind
test mensuel philippe corti
m
[Musique]
le pays
le maire
m
tous les canaux c'est parfait c'est
parfait shooter cadeau ce soir ont
chauffé la salle libye mesdames
messieurs
oh
[Musique]
et pour big blind test l'idée portée
je
à
et attend capitaine que j'étais
que je
didierjean
oui mais le soir
c
merci merci pour lui vous méritez
beaucoup plus évidemment vous êtes le
footballeur français le plus titré
l'un des footballeurs mondiaux les plus
titrés aussi de ligue des champions l'om
en 93 la juventus en 96 champion de
france 90 92 champion d'italie 95 97 98
coupe d'italie 95-97 coupe d'angleterre
avec chelsea en 2006 champion du monde
en 98 cents pions d'europe en 2000
recordman des sélections 103 matches
avec les bleus et recordman des matchs
comme capitaine 53 sélections mais là
messieurs
un triomphe romain un triomphe romain
haas assez
c'est gracieux ultime ici ça
nous sommes
merci à tous didier deschamps donc alors
le seul problème vous ai jamais eu la
coupe de france si jamais joué de finale
non la seule année où j'aurais pu la
jouer c'était malheureusement lors des
incidents de furiani un été en demi
finale et donc j'ai eu la chance de
jouer je me coupe de france in an à
bombay tournée prochain j'ai fait cette
année encore sa sauvegarde et d'un coup
je sais pas trop
oui alors désormais vous êtes reconverti
depuis que vous avez quitté dans les
produits laitiers
mais en sport en fête
ainsi les biscuits michel a dit que ça
mais les biscuits salés aussi
c'était en 68 à bayonne au pays basque
jusque là tout va bien dans un milieu
ouvrier
votre mère de travail de 7 heures du
matin à sept heures du soir comme
vendeuse et votre père il est peintre à
l'aérodrome de biarritz il travailler
les samedis et dimanches
donc ça bossait beaucoup j'ai les gens à
payer pour gagner un peu plus d'argent
il avoue tout payer la maison
voilà entre autres comme nous tous alors
vous manqué de rien mais pas de superflu
quoi oui ça vous a donné des bonnes
bases tout ça de certains repères vous
allez valeur faisant la famille les
valeurs familiales
l'homme de l'homme du pays basque en
faire voilà c'est assez carré comme mec
quoi on peut appeler ça comme ça mais
peu un peu têtu quoi oui très justement
comme vous êtes base quand j'étais petit
vous allez à là à la chasse à la pêche
comme ça avec votre père est un jouet
sont venus vous voir pour le parti
pêcher à ses traditions et vous
embarquer je vous avais pas compris que
c'est un parti vous donc à ce que ce
soit mais bien sûr jean st gelais
enrôler oui tout à fait dit non je ne
participe pas ça c'est vrai que je
défend ses idées afin de valider le fait
de la page la pêche la chasse la nature
chez quelqu'un de très nature mais une
fois hors de question de participer à un
parti politique
et puis dans leur liste ou bombes des
champs non plus sa voix des électeurs
sans doute quoi donc
alors l'état voulait pas en parler le
terrain non c'est pas un sujet que j'ai
envie d'un vrai nom c'est suffisamment
grave et puis du fait de mon image et
public il vaut mieux pas faire de
commentaire parce que ce sera toujours
mal interprétés comme je vous ai pas
peur je vais pas dire que j'ai peur mais
lorsque je
je vois ce qui est arrivé à mon ami
bixente lizarazu c'est vrai que ça porte
à réfléchir et je suis surtout très
triste pour lui et j'espère ne jamais
connaître cette situation
est-ce que c'est pas quand même un peu
la terreur là c'est à dire que vous
pouvez pas vous exprimer parce que vous
avez peur de représailles sur votre
famille ce qu'ils font pas régner la
terreur ben si oui il ya la terreur il
ya la peur je m'exprime mais bon en tant
que j'ai une image publique je préfère
ne pas m'exprimer banderas aussi vous ai
parlé d'eux et résout et à banderas
aussi qui est menacée oui je sais je
savais que ça serait bien
bon alors on continue vaudeville j'ai
fait des études collège catholique à
bayonne
vous étiez doué en maths et en physique
mais vous dites y avait pas fait du foot
j'aurais pu le faire la gestion et
l'économie pense que j'avais certaines
facilités
j'ai continué continuer après par la
suite moi j'ai dû m'arrêter pour
incompatibilité avec le football
alors pourquoi au pays du rugby faisait
choisi le foot je pense c'est venu
naturellement j'ai joué au rugby aussi
ça me plaisait mais je me sentais plus à
l'aise avec un avec un ballon parce que
mes camarades les plus proches et jouer
au football donc pour rester avec eux je
joue au football aussi vous commencé
très tôt une première licence à l'âge de
12 ans cet art avant vous trouvez ça tu
as repris par rapport à mort pourquoi ne
pas commencer à l'heure actuelle est à 6
ans 7 ans ils sont déjà avant dans des
clubs avec des parents qui les harcèle
au bord du terrain qu'attendent à l'âge
de 7 ans au bord du terrain signée par
an qui pousse le papa qui voudrait que
sens absolument footballeur avec l'idée
des éducateurs qui sont pas toujours
quand votre père vous demande pourquoi
vous n'avez pas joué aux genêts d'anglet
vous dit au coach bird pendant d'enlever
ce nombre avec sans votre coeur
quand votre père vous demande pourquoi
vous n'avez pas joué au gène et d'anglet
vous dites aucun joueur n'est jamais
sorti de la base et c'est déjà vachement
motivé parce que déjà dès le départ vous
prenez l'aviron bayonnais est pas les
genêts d'anglet
oui aujourd'hui parce que souvent vous
ai tendance à dire anglais ou les
attentions
quand vous avez revenu à la barre après
la suite de votre gueule c'est pas sans
cautionner d'anglais non mais dès le
début
voilà dès le début vous visez la
réussite mais je pensais pas je sais pas
pourquoi je me rappelle avoir dit ça
mais pourtant pour moi le football
c'était pas si t'es pas un métier je
voyais pas ça comme comme revenir
professionnel c'était un jeu mais bon
tant qu'à prendre une licence et être
dans un club hôte ont gagné au temps où
aller dans une équipe qui prennent pas
des raclées tous les week-ends j'aimais
pas perdre donc à partir de là ça c'est
sûr dès le plus jeune âge vous détestez
père vous dit l'important c'est pas de
jouer c'est de gagner si vous êtes anti
coubertin mais ça change c'est ma
doctrine à jouer pour jouer ça
m'intéresse pas beaucoup c'est gagné et
du plaisir à travers la victoire mais
comme j'étais petit les gens d'ici et ne
quand vous perdiez sa théorie vous
parliez pas aux autres leur faisait la
gueule vous les traitez petit écart au
rude comme il dit chez moi ça m'irait la
tetra enfin donné j'étais piquer des
crises non les insupportables mauvais
joueurs puisque c'est mon fils et moi et
deux vous avez perdu une finale de coupe
d'aquitaine je passe d'être les
mini-bleus pleurer après ça vous touche
est vraiment aux rares dans la défaite
nous faisons des prières pour gagner non
maintenant à faisait à l'époque
après l'arrêté l'arrêté quand votre la
mort vous aussi oui j'ai changé un peu
l'attitude je suis catholique mais bon
je suis pas pratiquer le droit
incroyable qu'avant vous voyez plus ce
destin cadieux maintenant ah oui tout à
fait pour nous taper une salle à quoi
bon alors ensuite vous partez en
formation à nantes 1 bat bordeaux
il faut dire que les mecs de bordeaux
baisse des coûts j'étais venu chez vos
parents en limousine il des cigares des
grosse mallette et en disant à votre
père quand vous voulez pour votre fils
est vrai que c'est pas très élégant sont
impressionnants ouais c'est vrai je veux
vendre ou de maquignons mais c'est mon
grand père qui disait ça ouais l'indicé
des vraiment kenyans mais ça
donnez tout à fait cette image là quand
on a acheté un bon petit bout d'chou
je tenais à vous le nourrir et puis si
l'epa bande revient à jeter une bourse
après c'est fini mais si ça marche pas
après c'est dur donc vous allez à nantes
et là c'est dur parce que vous retrouvez
à l'âge de 14 ans seule dans cette
grande ville puis en plus ce centre de
formation j'imagine que d'émulation non
c'est la jungle en plein il faut pas
avoir on a une image un peu dorée du
centre de formation dit moi je suis
arrivé j'ai eu la malchance qu'on ait
parlé beaucoup de moi comme est présenté
comme la future star et je suis arrivé à
15 ans il y avait d'autres joueurs entre
15 et 18 ans ils me l'ont fait payer un
petit peu qua non mais bon ça fait pas
puis j'ai été accepté après c'est comme
ça il faut savoir se bat vous apprenez à
vous dépasser dans tous les cas là bas
et puis au bout de mon dû commencer à
prendre des cuites avec eux ça devient
plus sympa non une surtout mémorable la
grande scène théâtre ah ouais d'accord
c'est vrai et puis bon encontre et
marcel desailly
oui voilà qui est devenu votre votre
grand ami par la suite donc c'est sûr
alors déjà la base j'étais capitaine au
centre de formation vous êtes vraiment
un leader né non c'est un chef
je sais pas où ça s'est fait
naturellement ce qu'il faut être pour
être chef mais bon pas retouché passé on
m'a confié des responsabilités dès le
début vous avez été habitué à être en
contact avec la presse et que les médias
de par la même qu'au départ le soleil
j'étais au devant de la scène donc à
partir de là j'ai très vite compris
comment fonctionnaient les médias alors
là on arrive à la fiche 69 non mais
c'est une tradition dans cette émission
et les rôles sont inversés évidemment
donc c'est vous qui allez me poser une
question j'ai une question indiscrète
j'ai une rumeur que j'ai entendu ce que
je voudrais savoir si c'est une légende
est ce que c'est vrai que vous ne portez
nickel sont ni un slip ou caleçon islip
y avait souri voilà c'est en vente libre
quelque chose elle va être bien d'autres
émissions sont effet inscrit des slogans
creux champs dans votre premier match
procès contre brest 16 ans et demi vous
n'êtes pas très doué techniquement nom
et qui a dit ça c'est ce que c'est ce
que j'ai vu dans tous les nombreux
articles que j'ai lu on dit que vous
êtes un bon dribble pas bon de la tête
vous avez une frappe qui est pas très
puissante oui elle était au départ moi
ça me sert pas ça me sert pas que ça ça
me sert pas spécialement non pas besoin
de faire des ailes de pigeon nécessite
un peu de truc qui me disent on j'étais
pas un surdoué j'ai beaucoup travaillé
mais j'ai pas l'aisance d'un zidane
thierry henry je peux à l'attaquant qua
non non vraiment pas non je l'étais
quand j'étais jeune je marquais beaucoup
de buts a bon oui je te là vous avez dit
combien de buts 4 en équipe de france en
équipe de france je manquais 22 23 24
buts dans toute ma carrière pour le
moment pas spécialement plus ça va moins
ça va plus ça va plus je vais finir
derrière le gardien entraîneur derrière
fabien h peu plus votre génie c'est le
placement dont vous avez toujours une
fois être c'est ça ça fait partie de mon
jeu mais bon le football se joue quand
même avec les pieds donc c'est pour ça
que quand on dit que bon je suis pas
très technique
si quand je dois mettre le ballon à
gauche on va toujours à droite je voyais
des problèmes quand même
on a reproché que j'ai récupéré beaucoup
de ballons que j'en perdais beaucoup
aussi avait au fil du temps ça s'est
amélioré mais bon j'arrive quand même à
faire obéir sur le ballon mais il se
repère bien son terrain
pas d'essai ou celles dont la meinau
stade il peut y aller tous j'ai une
oreillette
j'ai une oreillette gros progrès depuis
brest ça c'est un truc qu'on apprend
dans le bouquin c'est que vous êtes un
sacré vanneur en fait c'est vrai quand
on veut voir ça ah ouais en fait de très
bonne heure c'est un truc sont bien en
découlent pas avec les médias mais abu
sud ça va
la savane way particulier je réponds pas
des questions de football donc à
vallorbe avec moi il n'y a pas de danger
à 20 ans vous êtes capitaine de nantes
dit alors la même saison vous êtes vous
êtes sélectionné pour la première fois
dans les bleus qui sont à l'époque le
coaché par un parent platini mais bon
tout le monde vous le dis quoi il a il
n'a pas été très simple avec vous
platini c'est ce qu'on me dit mais
pourquoi je sais pas si c'est moi j'ai
de bons rapports avec lui c'est
quelqu'un que je respecte énormément que
j'ai jamais voulu critiquer parce qu'il
n'est pas critiquable pour moi mais bon
pourtant quand je le vois qu'il est
toujours le sourire devant vous il la
ramène pas
non je le chante vraiment c'est un privé
quoi je me gêne pas non plus mais ça
s'arrête là alors il a dit que vous
étiez un joueur peu spectaculaire sans
génie pas un grand joueur mais pas celui
des jaloux parce qu'il n'a jamais eu la
coupe du monde je suis demandée j'espère
pas si l'année à être jaloux geraghty ni
par rapport à tout ce qu'il a fait j'ai
déjà aidé d'autres joueurs qu'ils soient
aigris et jaloux je peux le comprendre
sans citer de noms mais que michel
platini sur comme ça non pour moi c'est
pas alors d'abord ces cantonales
capitaine des bleus 1 jusqu'à que ce
talent pallaske ce qu'il fasse ses
bêtises ouais je veux c'est possible je
sais qu'il faut si vous allez bien non
je sais qu'il a fait des bêtises et si
on parlait c'est que vous l'appréciez
beaucoup d'arrivées bien sûr comme
footballeur comme être humain comme
leur jeu fait d'un arrêt comme toi et
laisse pas indifférent comme amy des
mois que cantona pour moi sur mac sans
moi je les aime bien que max max anstie
cantona ou c'est pas voulu et fait virer
quand même non ah non j'ai pas ce
pouvoir là non parce que cantona qui
vous a traité de porter douce ou oui
j'ai pensé l'eau pour lui pendant cinq
ans donc c'est pas du tout
maintenant didier deschamps quand je
vais jouer avec la juge vous avez été
entendu par un juge d'instruction
turinois ont des problèmes de fuselage
de dopage maison de créatine qu'en est
il exactement
j'ai été confrontée trois fois oui c'est
vrai à un juge d'instruction qui avant
même de poser des questions étaient
persuadés que
il y avait du dopage dans le football
qu'on utilisait le p o
donc c'est très difficile de
de faire face à un tel personnage la
créatine aussi c'est vrai qu'elle est
utilisée elle autorisée dans ces pays
certains pays dans notre nom j'en ai
pris pendant une certaine période après
j'ai arrêté je pense pas que ça soit un
produit nocif même si certains
spécialistes le disent mais le dopage en
règle générale et je pense qu'il y en a
dans le sport dans le football j'ai pas
été confronté parce que je pense
sincèrement je vois pas l'utilité
je crois pas que le dopage est un
produit peu d'un
la joueur bidan peut faire un super
joueur ça jamais fait tirer dans les
lucarnes je vois pas trop l'utilité ça
peut faire courir plus vite ça peut être
plus résistants mais il ya le ballon et
le balance initiés il faut savoir le
diriger donc des matchs très souvent
même temps donc la répétition évidemment
qu'on a des aides
evo pharmaceutiques pour aider à
récupérer mais ce juge là ils partaient
du principe moi c'est ce qu'il m'a dit
enfin d'interrogatoire il me dit je
voudrais arriver à faire une loi que le
footballeur ci prend un produit une
vitamine c peut importe où on est
enrhumé ou qui prend quelque chose la
semaine à voir le match il ne puisse pas
jouer un match il y aurait plus beaucoup
de football à la télé ça va bien merci
de votre sincérité milieu des champs la
question qui tue
quand guy deschamps vous confirmer c'est
comme à la télé pas de dopage dans le
football tu viens alors maintenant je
vous faire tant pis pour vous une
interview nul en les bouches pendant le
single
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai peur comme celui baptiste vaut une
belle pièce convaincu baptiste aussi
cette famine mon mari va se marier
c'est une tradition familiale baptisant
chez vos convictions
d'accord je respecte toutes les
convictions tout celle là surtout celle
là oui alors interview nul donc j'ai des
questions très très con je pourrais
prendre comme à bahia pas de moi je sais
bien les poser je pensais alors est ce
que vous préférez pierre ou ginette
j'avais dit que c'est qu'on s'est on
parle des mêmes ouais parce qu'il va
beaucoup de bénéfices et vote votre
pierre baux de papa pierre et votre
moment ginette non pas faire un choix
entre ses paras s'il faut en tout les
deux c'est un formidable les deux donc
on va choisir sincèrement vous arrivez
pas là non
entre hitler et staline vous préférez à
quai
à vous en foutez c'est pas vos parents
là je vois pas du tout les deux non il
n'y a pas de troisième à choisir
j'aurais ma faute c'est tout mais c'est
pire encore bien alors vous partez dans
un vaisseau spatial pendant trois ans je
crains le pire
alors lire une île déserte avec l'insee
glisse au spatial avec qui vous préféré
partir
cantona tapis ou locaux ouais c'est un
problème en moins je vais apprendre des
choses
oui ça c'est sûr vous allez apprendre
des trucs à l'air de pas négativement on
aime on n'aime pas mais il laisse pas
indifférent ah oui c'est moi j'ai
beaucoup appris il m'a dit beaucoup de
vérité est-ce que vous préféreriez
mourir tout de suite là maintenant l'a
pas vraiment et aller au paradis ou
vivre trente ans de plus et aller en
enfer
je prends les trente ans ouais pas grave
après vivre sur terre le corps n'est sûr
de rien après un 65 sont pas d'accord
les petits gars tu arrives désertes car
il allait bien c'était dernier de
légères de vous préféré partir avec une
fille très moche ou un mec très beau
pour aller à la pêche ouais alors la
pêche au thon
alors autant alors ouais c'est une
question qu'on gérait c'est vraiment con
j'ai répondu comme un gage est pas bon
avec la fiq un fil très moche ouais de
taper des du tout non vraiment prêt
n'ont pas non vie vraiment sûre si le
désert partirions enfin à chaque fois si
vous partez sur une île déserte doit
être la même à mon avis parce qu'elle
allait chanter là il rabaisse pas parce
qu'alain savimbi et d'insectes volants
là j'y vais pas merci allez les filles
qui envoient des emails en disant moi si
samuel le bihan vu une fille moche c'est
si guillaume canet avait une fille moche
je suis d'accord une foyer quoi vous
pariez fille moche ou m non mais vous
savez moi je m'excuse mais très beau
système
nicolas c'est pour les filles s'est
inversée oui je sais pas j'ai pas
inversée alors qu'elle a fait dimanche
et moche ouais mec très bon mec très
moche que va filtrer base il ya un mec
très moche ça se trouve il est très
intelligent
bon voilà fait une très belle est
forcément très qu'on souhaite
ça m'arrange
bien c'est la télé vous préféreriez
adopter des jumeaux cleptomane des
jumelles pyromanes j'avais averti
cleptomane alors les jumeaux club thomas
oui parce que des chimères qui remet
dans la région vous vivez en plus c'est
mieux que les taux moi ça ramène des
trucs à la maison je peux être regardé
en slip de sega en slip de tibéri ou en
slip de delanoë en fait pas un
conseiller comme vous je porte
il est venu me dire qu'elle s'en va
c'est bien triste tout je sais rien
changé voici judith godrèche
j'y reviendrai finale messieurs alzonne
averti ce soir il ya que des filles
ouais mais pas vraiment libre judith
donc ça va être difficile mais enfin bon
j'ai dit vous nous avez raconté la
dernière fois où vous étiez invité dans
cette émission comment vous aviez
interrompu votre carrière pendant deux
ans au moment où elle devenait
internationale pour faire un enfant avec
dany boon
ce qui est génial votre show c'est
fantastique ce qui vous arrive c'est
qu'à peine l'enfant aîné que déjà votre
carrière redémarre au plan international
avec quick centre de john mackenzie avec
michael keaton et michael caine et donc
vous allez maintenant partir en amérique
pour tourner la suite
[Applaudissements]
alors le tournage a commencé à nice
c'est ça non mais non mais j'ai eu du
bol parce que juste moment j'ai décidé
de retravailler après avoir allaité mon
fils qu'on a un an je me suis dit bon le
bien de la chance vous ayez pas peur de
succomber à la tentation là-bas de pick
and go laquelle tous les beaux garçons
qui à los angeles à tom cruise ce
calibre en plus il vient de divorcer ni
le petit malawi
ils vous laissent partir dany boon ouais
la confiance mais il est sûr salle est
en train de vivre un prion enfin - bah
ouais mais les américains sont très très
haut ils n'ont pas le droit de parler
aux filles parce que c'est tout les
isabelle alonso qui ont gagné là bas
donc évidemment dès qu'ils regardent
prison après c'est les mecs tu es donc
il n'est pas inquiet un nom bon on va
parler de lui un petit peu
au départ c'est un peu un drôle de coup
parce que vous n'êtes pas du tout du
même milieu lui il est fils d'un non
routier d'une femme de ménage les ch'tis
me dire qu'il est du nord
vous êtes comédienne fait des films
d'auteur un page timmy fils de
psychanalystes et pourtant vous êtes
mariés depuis quoi trois ans je sais pas
en fait pas si moi je vous le dirai mais
je compte les jours
il n'y a pas de problème mais non non
non il ya pas de problème mais c'est ça
être adulte oui savoir faire des
compromis d'accord alors on s'est
rencontré sur le tournage de bimboland 1
et on peut dire que votre couple a mieux
marché que le film quand la main annonce
a pas mal marché pour la banque pour un
film raté sa démarche
non mais c'est vrai que c'est pas un
film réussi ouais ouais c'est pas grave
vous êtes rencontrés de l'essentiel nous
dès qu'on perd on l'a pas vu vous l'avez
avions il ya beaucoup de gens qui
l'avait laissé leur nom mais ce que je
veux c'est gentil sympa l'attraction moi
j'ai rien compris
ça serait bien c'est une meilleure idée
car à tokyo disneyland mais la sauce à
part l'a pas prise
non mais le scénario était très bien
mais en fait c'était juste pas un film
pour ariel s'est il je pense que voilà
il s'en est rendu compte ans dans le
film et zeitoun c'est le réalisateur du
film ça lui plaisait pas il est une
personne était heureux lui les voyez
c'est dans le problème c'est que la leaf
et xxl avant déjà
[Applaudissements]
y en a marre bien alors fait la mise en
scène des spectacles de dany vous avez
fait le titre vous avez fait les
costumes vous avez fait des décors vous
avez vous une influence sur lui n'en
attend que ça enfin bon de manipuler un
peu quand même
non non la preuve quand il a été
question de justement de faire un enfant
et que on se dit bon ben voilà on peut
pas faire un enfant si moi je suis à mes
hommes et à mexico et lui il est en
tournée on en a parlé et si je l'avais
manipuler j'imagine qu'il aurait annulé
son spectacle
oui c'est beau ce témoin c'est vous qui
avez tout annulé j'ai travaillé pendant
un an et lui l'aurait vraiment pas fait
c'était c'est un truc dont il était pas
capable mais je le comprends d'ailleurs
il faudrait comme séjour ils fassent un
sacrifice pour vous donner c'est vrai un
tel avertissement enceinte tout se passe
bien entre vous ouais ça va très ok ok
donc au casino de paris en parfait état
elle n'a pas fait du tout invité à boire
pour moi
la plus charmante hésite là c'est bien
patate
ouais tu aurais pas dû dire ça je
trouvais un légume tu vas te conduire
coli c'est bien c'est bon c'était le nom
d'un producteur de cinéma surtout
brocoli alors embarcations journée
seront ils produisaient du possible
hausse avec lagaf maintenant il commence
la paix ne dit pas de la gare lagaf est
mon ami un vincent
ces évolutions la semaine prochaine
en fait j'ai un autre chemise en ce
moment si vous c'est beau comme couleur
la vodka celan m mais qui a été lavé une
fois c'est ça bien alors vous allez
partir seul aux etats-unis les attaques
pourri d'emplois va enfin les noms et
les fusils coup c'est connu on s'est
connus au début août ce nom alors vous
allez partir seul aux états unis on va
on va faire un petit test pour savoir si
amoureusement vous êtes comment ça se
passe parce que nous on est inquiet pour
dany d'une certaine façon
attention ça s'appelle l'interview
alerte euros
[Musique]
ce rapport la bouche par jean yanne
hommage à denis en même temps ouais on
est chez nous
ben ali désolé il a pas que ça 4 avec ok
voilà pourquoi il a laissé partir aux
etats-unis
quelle est votre première pensée judith
godrèche lorsque vous rencontrez un
homme séduisant
où vais-je ouais vous préférez draguer
ou faire draguer la cassette parlez vous
de demain comme ça ex concours drague
préféré embrasser ou vous faire
embrasser me faire embrasser roxas pas
de wayne attendra ce quelqu'un en
l'occurence il est quand même tu peux te
jeter sur lui qu'elle est une action ce
soir c'est décalé gonzesses déjà c'est
ça que et pour vous j'ai livré le lieu
idéal pour une étreinte attend que je
réfléchisse man unique huawei
vous auriez d'une plage ça va être tué
d'être le lieu où vous êtes incapable de
faire l'amour
ben les toilettes
ah bon mais c'est vachement sympa bah
ouais pour concentrer sur mon jeu mais
déjà fait
est-ce que presse avait caressé ou vous
faire caresser ou ça
les engins
et maintenant seigneur sith où nous en
sommes envers bp chela alors ça c'est
très important
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour pour
aimer des mets pour faire l'amour ah bon
on peut pas faire l'amour sans aimer si
je peux mais c'est pas forcément une
réussite
alors voilà une question aussi très
intéressante pour nos amis américains
est ce que vous préférez un mec qui
bosse bien mais qu'il ya un fidèle ou un
mec qui baisent mal mais qui est fidèle
les mecs qui qui vont très vite et tout
est au bout de deux minutes voilà moi
j'ai connu ça vous avez connu ça deux
accusateurs précoce ouais ça doit être
terrible non à wes mls est terrible mais
quand on est une fille ont toujours tron
se trouve toujours des excuses à tout ça
mais mme ducharme en fait ouais non
c'est vrai mais moi je veux infirmières
donc dès qu un mec plein de problèmes à
la limite c'est donc vous préférez un
mec qui bosse bien et qui est infidèle
ou un mec qui bosse mâles des quais
fidèle infidèle dans un couvent vous
pensez qu'il vaut mieux tout se dire ou
rien savoir
tout se dire ah bon mais je pense que
l'infidélité c'est un langage c'est un
mode de langage c'est pour dire à
l'autre tu assures pub ça va pas un
problème ça c'est mal fort en même temps
j aime très fort et je t'es trompé baril
mais l'afrique vraiment si je couche
avec lui ça va pas entre nous
moi je pense qu'une fois qu'on a trompé
quelqu'un c'est fini tu crois ouais
c'est très difficile mais une fois j'ai
trouvé quelqu'un et après c'était fini
quoi il n'y a pas moyen d'en informer
les morceaux ce que tu dis est ce à la
personne est suspicieuse à tout le monde
si vous l'aviez dit bout et il l'a
découvert mais moi je faisais tout pour
que cela se sache vous êtes une fille
très spécial oui je lui accorde aussi
d'ailleurs
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut tout
faire quand on aime way to two two way
n'a rien de sale en amour non saison du
polémique
est-ce que vous avez un fantasme non
encore assouvi carrément avec des pommes
de terre
non non mais j'ai pas tellement de
fantasmes fait comment ou alors vous
avez tout a souri ils sont peut-être est
uni mais peut-être j'ai pas tellement de
fantasmes
y'a pas un truc vous dit comme ça
j'aimerais bien le faire j'aime bien moi
c'est les chiens sur la bouche oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lui aussi voit si dany boon
que
tout avec lui libre
et c'est l'amour
[Musique]
il chante non les blues auraient pas le
seront pas
holy boom à l'oreille comment ça va ça
va pas mal bien on a eu votre compagne
oui si je dis oui c'est comme ça qu'on
dit c'est comme ça c'est comme ça que
j'ai découvert l'émission
voilà ma femme l'a fait tout le temps
dont elle est sans arrêt alors je lui
dit quand tu veux un tueur vient est la
bienvenue
ça vous embête quand on vous dit que
vous êtes le mari de judith godrèche non
pas du tout c'est pas du tout ça me
flatte quand elle est venue on lui a
demandé si elle vous courtisaient
si elle avait pris possession de votre
esprit elle a dit non non de demande de
mon corps et parfois de mon escrime sava
libre-arbitre où vous pouvez faire tout
ce que c'est au début les premiers
gagnent jour j'étais comme ça alors
le mieux est des fois ça revient
défendre la regardant
oui
dans votre vie votre vrai nom c'est
daniel hamidou et dany boon en fait
c'est le nom d'un héros de séries en
fait non d'un trappeur c'est un copain
qui faisait les daniel boone il
s'appelle le héros kkk existait
d'ailleurs qui était un canadien qui a
traversé l'alaska
voilà à pied ah oui comme ça bien et
donc c'est venu logiquement alors vous
êtes né à armentières un point bas mais
fier en 1966 et vous savez laurent
qu'armentières c'est le pays 2
celle ci line renaud là
chansons de line renaud sur sont
méconnus ne seriez pas ça
elle a fait des trucs grave au feeling
renault votre père vient de kabylie est
arrivée en france à ces jeunes était
boxeur il est quelques victoires
d'ailleurs sur le ring à alger à
marseille sa vie en faisant de la boxe
attend de la boxe et puis un jour il a
raccroché les gants et il a pris le
volant de 1,3 tonne d'un 38 3 tonnes
c'est par un camion s'est même pas le
poids d'une voiture
l'autre tête c'est un gros cul qui
connaît
[Applaudissements]
un 38 tonnes [ __ ] j'ai pas le permis
en même temps moi comme j'ai dit voilà
donc voilà donc un jour il raccroche les
gants il prend les commandes d'un gros
camion 10 on est tous les matins il va
faire le plein de super dans une station
service commercial de gasoil
[Musique]
ce réseau là t'es tu t'appelais pas max
meynier jusque et transporte bien donc
tout cas l'arrière il ya une sorte de
grande cabine c'est pas un appartement
d'accord les bisons des marchandises et
donc tous les matins il va faire le
plein de gasoil dans la station service
des parents de votre mère voilà et un
jour votre mère se retrouve enceinte
parce que derrière il ya aussi celles où
il ya une couchette
quand votre merde se retrouve enceinte
elle a 17 ans a eu 36 oui
sans commentaire il s'est excusé ouais
et vos grands-parents coupe les vivres
dont ils ont été sérieux qu'ils ont été
obligés d'habiter dans le camion au
moment
oui c'est vrai les réalités d'un parce
que mes grands parents s'ils n'ont pas
supporté l'idée way que ma mère soit
enceinte surtout d'un étranger donc
c'est un drame
tu pars ouais donc elle est partie dans
le camion c'est mes arrière grands
parents qui ont aidé mais c'est sympa ça
je savais pas oui oui oui c'est sympa ça
je savais pas du tout alors votre maire
bah oui on est obligé de faire des
ménages parce que c'est compliqué il ya
en plus de petits frères qui arrive et
puis un jour il décide d'acheter cette
fameuse maison mais en deux corps ont à
crédit c'est vrai parce qu'on va voir la
fin là je on va voir comment c'est
l'histoire de la maison se termine c'est
pour ça que je dis ça c'est une chute
bien enfance très dure pour vous là on
rigole mais bon enfance très dure père
très sévère relations conflictuelles ça
se traduisait comment le ceinturon comme
il était boxeur et des heures sup quoi
perdre du temps
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes un enfant dany boon assez
introverti
à l'époque oui c'est d'ailleurs presque
autiste et vous quitter le foyer
familial à l'âge de 15 16 ans oui oui
c'est ça 15 ans alors banon cette
enfance évidemment ou de puiser de quoi
faire ce que vous faites aujourd'hui
c'est une sorte de thérapie en fait
en fait les gens aimeraient beaucoup
j'ai été très introverti je parlais pas
énormément je regardais les gens quoi et
je vais vous voyez les copains de mon
père ou le et donc ouais et puis j'ai
observé que oui une galerie de
personnages dans votre spectacle et
votre mère alors là mais un truc c'est
qu'elle racontait des choses horribles
en star d'andré un manque effectivement
vous c'est ce que vous faites fi
nalement week cette journée quoi
et les gens étaient atterrés l aile avec
lille bien ouais elle tournait en
dérision les journées tout en dérision
alors l'histoire voilà j'en arrive à
l'histoire de la maison parce que c'est
pas innocent ils vont divorcer un peu
comme les parents de marie gillain
je suis devenu un spécialiste marché et
vous vos parents divorcent après 25 ans
et ils ont vendu cette maison est passé
leur vie à la payer cette maison il l'a
vendu pour cent mille balles c'est
magique ce pourquoi votre mère à contrer
ça sur mon smartphone mais c'est un peu
dur mais ça tout le monde serait murder
et à séoul - non mais bon 25 ans de
boulot et puis puissant mille balles oui
mais bon mes parents fin mon père était
très
très heureux de son métier ils aiment et
ce qu'ils faisaient et
donc voilà il gagne pas beaucoup
d'argent mais ça ouais ouais alors votre
père qu'il n'a pas connu votre succès
est décédé avant c'est un peu dommage
parce qu'au début il avait du mal à
accepter ou facile ça oui il avait dû y
avait du mal à accepter que je fasse il
voulait non le disait
je les jouais il m'a bien fait recteur
et paix dès la semaine prochaine dans
ses 80 pour lui c'était pas possible
cache non alors vous avez une vocation
assez assez précoce un très jeune à
l'école vous alors ses membres ce qu'il
allait se coucher dany boon
évidemment les palois de regarder le
film à la télé mais que vous avez
beaucoup d'imagination lendemain à la
cantine et raconter le film qui l'avait
pas vu aller à la cantine je voyais
juste un bout de film et j'inventais la
fin mais je vais monter la suite du film
j'ai raconté ça à mes copains et
toujours pareil était justement très
extraverti à l'extérieur à l'école
ouais et vous et du mime dans votre
chambre c'est très beau l'an c'est
complexe et à part mes oreilles oui
terriblement comme vous d'ailleurs un
petit peu moi ça m'a un peu passé oui
c'est vrai des cheveux plus longs plus
les j'ai les cheveux assez l'on envoie
moi oui alors vous faites un truc que
j'ai parlé avec votre coiffeur l'arrêt
pour vous faites une ré comme ça je sais
pas ce que je voulais je fasse d'autre
mais je sais pas il m'a dit oui pis il
me dit c'est au millimètre bien sûr je
veux une autre avec judith quand on le
regarde quand elle est pas ici mais ça
c'est pas souvent c'est que des fois là
avec vous aussi vous regardant 17
pourquoi vous ne tentez pas une autre
notre coupe de cheveux hpc si je faisais
part et de l'autre côté ça irait n'ont
pas de réelle intrigue un peu un peu
fouillis quoi un peu à moi non je peux
pas mal donc pourtant vous dormir avec
un élastique autour des oreilles c'est
ma mère qui m'a donné ce complexe et
quand j'étais bébé elle me trouvais très
très beau sauf les oreilles décollées
donc elle me mettait un élastique une
sorte de bonnet comme ça qui me
reconnaît les oreilles et l enlever le
matin c'est fou
et
[Applaudissements]
avez vous oublié gti dit j'ai fait beau
de trois quarts avec la tête légèrement
penchée comme ça parce qu'à l'envoyer
pas que j'avais des oreilles décollées y
avait un beau regard et les phillies et
à un torticolis à un moment vous quittez
la maison fait du mime dans la rue je
vais gagner 700 balle et pour vous c'est
énorme parce que votre père et pour vous
c'est une grosse somme
oui c'est ça surtout que j'avais dans la
tête qu'il fallait que je fasse soit la
sncf où un concours jean retraité sncf
où ma mère me répéter ça en pleure tout
le temps voir la fiche de paye ta à la
fin du mois pareil je disais mais c'est
pas écrit la poste et donc
et donc effectivement d'un seul coup
j'ai été embauché pour faire du mime
automate dans une grande surface et j'ai
eu un cachet le soir c'est 700 francs le
match j'ai halluciné
j'ai vraiment galéré quand même parce
qu'à une fois j'ai vu là vous jouiez
dans des espèces de bruit oui il fallait
déplacer le baby foot pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir jouer quand on fabrique est une
espèce de seine si jamais au téléphone
quelqu'un qui me dit ouais je la sens
culturel via faire bien faire ça la lune
heures et j'étais allé chez lui je suis
tombé dans un bistrot et
jeudi mais ya pas de scène il dit baby
au bout j'ai l'habitude joue à la place
j'avais dit il n'y a pas d'éclairage il
s'était pas annoncée c'est grâce à lui
même est bon et je le soir arrive et je
me suis dit tant pis je vais jouer ça me
fait envie de faire ça c'est mon rêve
quoi j'avais 16-17 ans et je donc je
reviens le soir il y avait donc la salle
bourrée donc quatre spectateurs est
bourré au comptoir le champ il chantait
déjà eu vraiment bourré je suis rentré
sur scène en me disant je vais tirer de
coup de feu j'avais un revolver un blanc
pour les faire taire pour pouvoir pour
qu'ils m'écoutent j'ai tiré deux coups
de feu y se sont tues moi il m'a regardé
comme ça et à ce moment là le berger
allemand du patron que j'avais pas vu
qui était derrière le comptoir me saute
dessus en croyant que j'attaquais c'est
vrai tout ça ils bouffent la jambe le
battre en direct qui bouffe dans le
comics et pour coller avec les quatre
spectateurs
mort de rire piccola il arrache de
chiens de montgenost l'arrachement genou
pour chien et le
leur part en coulisse vous recherchez un
tf1 en coulisses en cuisine ce que c'est
des cuisines je cherche un os de poulet
pour remplacer ma rotule et sa femme me
fais un pansement à la mayonnaise
c'est vrai il revient samedi après midi
j'ai mis le chat dans le break
hier tandis il faut les rigolos j'ai dû
retourner sur scène et y en a un des
quatre qui m'a dit au milieu du
spectacle m'a dit me cyril joufflu alors
voilà c'est tout c'est tout le talent
dont vous avez hérité de votre mère ça
c'est raconter des trucs terribles
maison serait il était évidemment des
frais après je me disais je vois là on
arrive maintenant à la fin puisque un
jour vous rencontrer thierry jolly le
frère de sylvie joly peser vos premiers
succès dont la déprime qui est votre
sketch le plus connu à l'époque
maintenance et c'est passé vous faites
toujours je me souviens pas donc voilà
vo de l'est maintenant je vais bientôt
pour arriver à la triche
quand tu pars de canal c'est long il ya
un temps de réponse très long mais pour
être pauvre quand on ne croit riches
c'est aussi avant que par le pognon
c'est très malin de mettre le plus de
l'abbé pierre
ces digues en année mais je préfère les
italiens
moi je suis ni six mois j'ai dû alors
claude allègre est ce que vous aimeriez
avoir un nez supplémentaires année
supplément des supplémentaires windows
supplémentaires un doigt supplémentaire
ou un sexe supplémentaires j'aimerais
avoir un oeil supplémentaire derrière
toi tu as peur de te remettre
alors aujourd'hui quand vous dites
finalement le mammouth c'est sympa je
préfère dinosaures parce que c'est
encore plus préhistorique que les
mammouths ces images du dinosaure et
plus est meilleure que celle du mahmoud
accord ou est-ce qu'il faut beaucoup de
temps pour les du cerveau halak voilà
c'est du vécu et on dit aujourd'hui
l'effet fernandes n'a pas joué il ya
plus qu il était prêt à jouer une vie
dure et qui n'apprécie pas plus que ça
ça va sortir dans l'internet et dans les
couloirs et appelle le baltringue
c'est vous qui me pose une question à
moi je l' ai vu je l' ai vu que ce
qu'elle est si bas est-ce que divin ou
put il dit et en plus ouais comme une
conne je répète dans votre nouveau 10
vous faites une chanson sur sur mantes
la jolie
oui on dire à ceux du val fourré que je
pense toujours à eux bien sûr d'ailleurs
un bon jour ils seront alloués à bonjour
mantes la jolie
oui bien sûr je dis à tous mes amis dose
de donges ou mantes-la-jolie et bonjour
les minguettes assez spéciale dédicace à
tous les pitbulls de croyants ouais je
vois bien bien bien sûr crois qu'un jour
les intentions pour remarcher
ouais première cuite et je crois en
pologne première cigarette au cabanis ya
pas très longtemps c'était à la jamaïque
arrive à marquer vous vous bourrez en
pologne
vous fumez vous fumer de l'herbe à la
jamaïque vous êtes lui arrive quelque
chose au bon endroit rouge premier
souvenir
le sourire de ma mère non là je peux pas
dire ça mais pas comme ça
pourquoi aux accents le sourire de ma
mère et moi ça fait déborder une belle
nana père lui c'était vraiment l'image
d'epinal il a bourré de pair avec la vie
privée encore technique pas revenons à
ces gens qui nous aiment
c'est quand même un peu dur sur vous les
mareyeurs bayonnais on ferait pas mieux
comme dire alors pardon laurent dory
glisser un conteneur écoute gagné 6
millions de dollars oui ça fait quoi 30
millions selon toi les [ __ ] la drogue
sur la ville
ce qui est plus sexy en vo c'est à dire
6 millions de dollars bien comme mec
jonas est reparti a compté pourtant
donné un traitement entre ce que vous
préférez dans le sexe le goût allez
vas-y non
bernard tapie tous ont commencé
réputation diplôme de même
comme toi je passe pour un de ses poids
pourtant on le fera quelles sont
bernard tapie bonsoir bonsoir vous
connaissez laurent baffie et comment
tient là j'ai un truc pour toi vous êtes
vus à à la première de canal j'ai fait
un cadeau
ouais je la paye ma n'a pas bravo a
parlé tout à l'heure dans la loge celle
d'origine parce que moi je l'avais
signer et faire celle d'origine je les
garde
voilà vous êtes libéré de prison voilà
c'est une carte c'est une carte du
monopoly et laurent baffie avait offert
en verlan sa fille à l'école laurent le
petit chat canal et oui bernard bonsoir
vouthon telle aventure sur une chaîne
une chaîne du câble s'appelle rtl 9 ans
l'émission s'appelle rien à cacher c'est
le dimanche à 19h20 donc et vous
interviewer une personnalité tous les
dimanches mais rtl9
vous êtes sûr bernard tapie que c'est
pas pour des raisons fiscales que vous
allez parce que c'est une société
française avant parce qu'on le siège est
à paris bon j'ai pas domicilié en
belgique en ce moment non j'aurais bien
voulu mais parce qu'il paraît que vous
recevez du courrier revenir si c'est
vrai puisque rester dans la vérité 1 3
rond point de l'étoile à ixelles c'est
dans la banlieue de bruxelles chez le
bourg mais ce qui s'appelle yves de
jonghe d'ardoye d'air [ __ ] vicomte
il paraît que vous recevez du courrier
chez lui non c'est parce que j'ai été
député européen pendant longtemps et
quand on est député européen on habite
au moins trois jours par semaine en
belgique à la carte et donc j'habitais
là bas et c'est ce qui fait que j'ai une
adresse belge et que j'ai un lieu de
résidence belle je me suis pas résident
dans la mesure où pour à ce statut vous
le savez le fisc imposa est ce vrai oui
on est plus de sens eu plus de 160 jours
par an voilà donc moi l'on va couvrir
d'un papier vous aider à voir à
l'étranger parce que tout le monde
là on va être moins mon désir tout voir
est-ce que tapie oui il aurait pas à
l'étranger des comptes macha pistons
j'en ai pas mais bien sûr c'est pas
seulement j'en ai crois pas
jamais jamais
bernard sérieusement ils ont tellement
cherché mais tellement tellement
tellement parce que ça leur faisait
plaisir
il ya un truc que je ne comprends pas
vous avez plein d'ennuis et vous avez
toujours votre hôtel particulier rue des
saints-pères nono manger c'est une
occupation à la fois partiel est
momentanée ouais en fait la famille
tapie à l'hôtel particulier à la maison
voilà ça te fait faire perçu c'est que
pour arriver à est riche
quand tu pars de que la halle c'est long
il ya un temps de réponse très long et
pour être pauvre quand on ne croit
riesch s'est lui aussi laissé des
langues la promo y en a qui ça va bien
il y en a qui savent à moins de le faire
mais toi et puis bernard aussi
bon alors donc la pulsé vol au-dessus
d'un nid de coucou en tournée et rtl9
dimanche ses démarches là à 19h20 sur
rtl9 sûr invités c'est qui santoni 110
demandes bien alors et puis attendez la
up
attention il ya l'om et bissé bic dit la
[ __ ] là ça fait mal big deal
alors là moi je crois qu'on est bon ou
c'est beau pardon d'abord on va faire un
petit flashback au mba pour vous c'était
le début de la fin
non c'était le déclic dans votre vie
c'était le début de la fin ça a été le
prétexte le prétexte voilà on vous dit
au début il ya belle lurette le vaincu
c'est quand je fais 12% européenne ouais
faut
après bon après avoir été ça ça aurait
pu être de la cam dans mon coffre ça
aurait pu être n'importe quoi chaos nva
il y avait mellick la semaine dernière
il génial qu'on m'a raconté son livre
j'ai pas eu le temps de le lire mais il
est génial parce qu' ils racontent une
histoire apparemment toujours la même et
il a je crois fini par y croire
alors je vais simplement dire à mon ami
mellick que j'adore parce que c'est
vraiment un mec qui a du coeur gai
fidèles que si j'avais été quoi que ce
soit quoi que ce soit dans la
construction de son faux témoignage
j'aurais été un peu inquiété pour faux
témoignage ou complicité de faux
témoignages bien alors maintenant d'un
tapis sérieusement vous êtes
juridiquement en mesure de demander une
licence de dirigeant de club auprès de
la ligue
oui parce que le droit en plus je vais
même vous en apprendre une qui est passé
à côté mais la ligue été condamné pour
me l'avoir retiré et il n'avait pas le
droit de me la retirer ça veut dire
qu'il ya eu et il ya des juristes qui
sont allés un peu cherché voir et qui se
sont pas contentés de l'histoire du sac
enterrés dans le jardin et qui fait
qu'après le conseil d'état estimé en
confirmant que je devais avoir le droit
d'avoir une licence
alors robert louis dreyfus il voulait
pas partir maintenant ils partiraient là
je sais pas en tout cas il a dépensé
beaucoup d'argent pour ne serait-ce
ultérieure pour peu de résultats 600
millions vous aviez mis 60 millions
ouais une à 1600 milliards et 10 et
l'émirat c'est vrai qu'il a gagné dans
la ddea donc lui l'annoncé ils sont
généreux avec le brouillon développe lui
l'ami 600 millions avec ses 600 millions
finalement il n'est pas arrivé
avec vous avec 60 bah ouais bah ouais
c'est un métier ça ouais mais alors
est-ce que voulez vous aider robert
louis dreyfus
ah ah ah ah non regardez le club lui ça
son sort m'intéresse pas ce qui
m'intéresse c'est là c'est le sort de
l'om
ouais et uniquement ça alors vous votez
à marseille vous êtes domicilié ou la
non mais c'est à l'époque où j'étais
simplement conseiller régional
conseiller départemental et donc
forcément lille
j'habitais marseille j'étais député des
bouches du rhône c'est toujours
électeurs à marseille
alors votre vie commence par une
incertitude en fait la première
incertitude c'est sur votre naissance
des dès le début il y avait déjà des
incertitudes avec vous bah oui je vous
est née sept mois après le mariage de
vos parents ben il ya deux solutions
soit vous êtes soit vous êtes en plus en
plus c'est pas ben si c'est pas vrai at
il commencé le 26 janvier quarante-trois
voilà et vos parents sont mariés en
juillet donc ça fait sept mois mais pas
en 43 vous êtes dans sonic et 43 vos
parents
vous ont conçu si vous ont conçu en
juillet 42 vous êtes né à sept mois
prématuré je suis né v6 en faute et
avant le mariage à dépassionner le débat
et d'amour qu'elle joue lundi 10 le
lundi suivant tu as fait tu là non mon
père je le crois tout à fait capables
d'avoir séduit maman est comme ça fait
maintenant 60 ans qui sont mariés
ensemble on peut éventuellement leur
pardonner d'avoir fait l'amour de dieu -
les deux mois voilà donc là moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est exactement la
formation de tags caractère comment vous
êtes devenu bernard tapie alors quand
vous êtes né votre père était au st lô
en allemagne jeudi pour nos amis qu'on
pas connu ça si le service du travail
obligatoire
tiens comme on prenait des français
pourrait travailler en allemagne il ya
beaucoup de jeunes communistes de jeunes
ouvriers communistes qui avaient été
emmenés en allemagne au west et au
notamment georges marchais était parti
travailler chez messerschmitt
[Musique]
alors votre père jean tapie était
ouvrier jean-baptiste lemoyne affiche
non
et moi je crois que votre problème vient
de là c'est à dire que finalement votre
père dans les espaces y est tu vas
écoute le tu vas voir car ton problème
j'ai même pas ton problème parce que je
vais d'excusés dans deux minutes et tu
es gentil là bas je pense d'un problème
de deep moi non mais sérieux évidemment
non mais voilà je vais vous dire
pourquoi vous le savez d'ailleurs votre
père lui tient le bon ouvrier le bon
ouvrier communiste le vrai quoi tient le
type qui est dur à la tâche qui veut
s'élever socialement mais à force de
travail du tout pourquoi pas du tout pas
du coup son caractère drag queen amis
l'ouvrier mon père ça bonnouvrier
commères plein air qui est honnête
sérieux c'est pas militant politique du
pays bas qui les militants politiques
jeudi que lui pour lui le travail s'est
il veut s'élever dans la hiérarchie
sociale tout le travail
il veut travailler pour nourrir ses
membres il fait en dix heures par
semaine au temps des bernard quand ils
valent usine la journée que le soir il
va à l'école des arts et métiers vont
s'élever socialement pas du tout c'est
pour avoir du boulot et nourrir sa
famille le vrai problème c'est votre
père c'est quelqu'un de très rigoureux
et vous voulez que je vous le dise à
prévoyez gré si c'est ça n'a rien à voir
à ça quand vous êtes né dans un milieu
qui soit peu importe on va pas faire du
misérabilisme
il ya plein de mômes qui sont très
malheureux d'être dans milieu de bourges
par exemple c'est quand vous êtes dans
un milieu et que l'environnement de ce
milieu ne vous plaît pas quel que soit
le milieu en question vous vous révoltez
d'une manière ou d'une autre tout faire
ya plein de monde qui sont bourrés et
qui se foutent dans des mouvements
trotskistes ya quatre ans parce qu'ils
supportent également
moi je ne supporte pas ce milieu parce
que c'est un milieu totalement
totalement soumis qui répond à rien et
de d'aucune manière à toutes les
agressions qu'on leur fait et à partir
du jour je deviens étudiant je vais à
paris et donc je suis en contact deux
mondes qui viennent d'ailleurs
il ya à la fois une révolte de ma part
de voir ces injustices car mon père est
intelligent il
travailleur il bosse seulement il a
baigné toute sa vie dans un milieu qui
lui permet pas de ces lois là et cette
injustice là me fait chier la voilà ça
rien à voir avec un complexe d'oedipe
attendez votre père c'est un cas
d'assécher une vraie bagarre social vous
êtes d'une famille unie vraiment vous
êtes une famille où on n'est pas très
expansif votre père est plutôt renfermé
vous êtes plutôt hâbleur plutôt expansif
justement et vous voyez votre père
travailler jour et nuit et finalement
être traitée plutôt pas très bien et
vous vous dites pour réussir il ya
sûrement des raccourcis à prendre et ça
a été et ça a été la raison de votre
opposition à votre père jour oppose jour
je n'explique la deuxième partie la
première partie on a compris pourquoi
des gosses pour sortir de leur milieu
font des efforts un peu surhumain alors
après il est question effectivement du
parcours qui est un parcours chaotique
sur lequel de temps en temps il ya une
ligne on franchit on la franchit pas ça
c'est autre chose
ça vient de deux phénomènes bien connu
le premier c'est que on connaît personne
et on connaît pas les règles et c'est
capital moi je vois mon fils y fait son
site trois jours après il à l'avocat qui
apprennent à l'expert compte à ce jour
après moi je connais aucune règle aucune
règle mais pas d affaire aucune règle
qui permettent à quelqu'un de s'élever
dans la société
donc je les invente et quand vous les
inventer vous êtes en parcours
initiatique vous faites des parcours bon
et des parcours mauvaise ya personne
pour vous dire là c'est bien là c'est
pas bien donc vous découvrez au fur et à
mesure l'itinéraire que vous devez
prendre on est d'accord mais va donner m
le 2e etc est aussi une des raisons du
handicap
si vous vous apercevez qu'on n'a pas
envie vous changer de catégorie
vous êtes bien là où ils assurent les
accords alors mais je suis d'accord avec
vous ce que je vous dis simplement c'est
que votre père lui il avait une vision
assez soumises effectivement des choses
vous vous dites c'est pas possible je
vais prendre des raccourcis un an je
suis révolté saria l'art avec les
raccourcis et verve je me suis par
exemple jamais permis jamais le car mais
pas le quart 10%
vous savez thirion le juge thierry henry
a dit dans un bouquin tapis à côté des
grands arnault pinault
c'est un enfant de choeur
parce que j'ai pas fait 10% bien sûr
parce que ce n'était pas du même milieu
social au départ bien sûr mais je
reproche rien avec le raccourci à cette
je vois je vous reproche pas l'aura
qu'on sait c'est qu'il est maintenant
peinture et dangereux ge serait supposé
c'est pour ça que je veux pas laisser ce
beau raccourci sourire le mucha course
il laisserait supposer qu'on n'hésite
pas de franchir les règles pour aller
plus vite c'est pas ça du tout mais vous
dites je connaissais pas les règles
toute façon mais je vais encore me mais
c'est vrai que votre père lui il avait
une vision plutôt traditionnel de la
réussite l'accumulation du travail du
temps passé et d'ailleurs vous est
jamais arrivé à l'impressionner votre
père c'est à dire qu'il a toujours été
votre réussite il a vécu comment il a
vécu comme quelque chose mais vous mais
ça va pas il était heureux à chaque fois
et moi pour le séduire j'étais content
j'étais en équipe de france juniors de
handball
il venait voir tous les matches je
faisais des concerts de viol on y venait
assister au concert c'est l'exacte maire
nous a mis aux violences qui était
prémonitoire est cependant bien ce à
quoi s'est bien avant vite et je suis
faible et que vous êtes sans le défendre
alors comme je dis qu'il faut les
parents mes parents ont eu une vertu
c'est de me donner et de m'apprendre
l'essentiel et je les en remercie dans
la mesure où c'est l'essentiel qui m'a
permis de tenir les élections le
terminer là dessus mais pourquoi votre
père quand il a monté sa pme dans les
années 60 vous chercher du boulot
pourquoi vous a jamais engagé c'est bien
parce que j'ai un problème avec lui mais
pas du tout il faisait des camions
réfrigérés et il a embauché mon frère
vous êtes dans ce milieu je dis pas que
ces causes est un vous avez un
appartement au bourget c'est un partage
bin voila je dis simplement qu'à un
moment vous avez décidé de trahir notre
classe sociale parce que c'est une façon
de laisser parent proche c'est une façon
de la volaille à vous en sortir une
vraie question d'ailleurs allé poser
souvent à ceux qui comme moi change
est-ce que c'est l'exemplarité de votre
réussite qui est positive et qui peut
donner envie à d'autres de dire c'est
possible donc on va le faire il ya eu le
cas est-ce que c'est au contraire une
manière totalement irréel
et j'allais dire insultante de faire
croire à des gens de sont des imbéciles
puisqu'ils le font pas il ya eu qu'à
aussi donc comme tous les symboles quand
vous faites des choses un peu qui
sortent de l'ordinaire vous est
symbolique
bah j'ai eu ma part de bons exemples
j'ai été positif et utile à certains et
j'ai été une catastrophe pour d'autres
c'est ce qui fait que dans ce pays les
gens qu'ils m'adorent et des gens qui me
détestent parce que je dis simplement
c'est qu'à l'époque quand vous allez au
bord de la marne à la fin des vacances
avec votre mère c'était non mais c'était
génial à vous souffriez mais génial un
peu traîné dans la main visiblement qu'à
un moment vous vous dis c'est pas c'est
bon là la vraie vie c'est pas ça et pour
s'en sortir quand on est dans votre cas
ya deux solutions il ya la boxe où le
rock'n'roll et vous avez choisi la
chanson c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
changer les eaux des femmes comme suit
ne s'est pas fait mieux c'est pas mieux
mais pas mieux mais c'est pas ça
l'itinéraire voulez pas vous sortir de
votre classe sociale et vous chercher
maintenant je sais déjà ressortir de la
soumission
c'est à dire quand je n'ose pas vous le
dire parce que je vais encore être un
mauvais exemple
mais je considère que par exemple voilà
la manière dont un représentant de la
force publique parle
un ouvrier dans sa voiture qui rit un
feu rouge m insupportable et maintenant
il me parle plus de cette façon là et je
suis content qu'ils me parle plus de
cette façon et j'aurais aimé qu'ils
parlent pas de cette façon là mon père
qui disait rien quand on le faisait
d'accord votre premier boulot c'est quoi
j'ai vendu des téléviseurs des géniales
c'était génial parce que c'est une
époque où il y en avait pas et donc
j'avais convaincu le gars qui était venu
pour en vendre 1 que s'il les prêtait
avec une antenne pendant quelques jours
il ya de grandes chances qu'ils auraient
plus envie de le laisser repartir
il m'a dit tu crois on en a mis 12 ans
un camion et sept minutes après l'es12
était placé les gens qui sortaient de la
wii aux moi j'en veux aussi moi j'en
veux aussi et puis fidon huit jours
après avec est-ce que ce n'était pas
déjà une façon de piéger les beaux
gosses je sais pas s'ils ont un
téléviseur
puis le laisser pendant huit jours en
disant attendre en fait nan vous disiez
passé à berlin l'institut de sondage ont
fait des études sur la télévision
non ça c'est donc on vous laisse le
téléviseur peut voir ce que vous pensez
des programmes qui peut pas l'accuser
d'être un mauvais vendeurs de hassan ont
créé des vendeurs qui te vendent un truc
qui te disent regarder l'écran dans 30
ans j'y suis chapeau noter quelques
clients quel que je dis aujourd'hui
après toutes ces aventures pas fini le
bon moment aujourd'hui je parle à moi je
sais pas faire un bilan un moment donné
de la vie parce que à 48 heures près tu
vois imagine je gagne mon procès contre
le lyonnais dans quinze jours quand on
se revoit je suis pas le même que si je
le perds ouais bah quand on se revoit
vous achetez tout la france deux mois
lui tout le monde mange achète pas vrai
vous achetez plus le nom du pot de colle
sérieusement vous avez su vous n'êtes
pas suivi toujours les conseils de votre
père et mon père il n'est pas
prétentieux au point de vouloir me
donner des conseils dès lors que je
quittais le chemin qu'il avait lui-même
parcouru le conseil s'est quand même pas
abstrait c'est mon expérience me permet
de te dire attention fais pas ça vaut
mon père dès lors que je quitte la
maison je fais des choses devraient le
faire il avait une autre façon que vous
de voir les choses totalement
il est discret il est modeste il est des
îles et il est réfléchi à tous les temps
tous les sens du terme
il est manuel il est capable de
fabriquer n'importe quoi moi non ouais
on est on est pas pareil
avant serge pas voir la lumière là
avant de quitter ce sujet est ce que
vous dites pas à sérieusement des fois
sérieusement quand vous êtes pas
maintenant que vous allez bien ça marche
mais quand vous étiez en cage comme vous
dites vous n'êtes pas l'idée fois
j'aurais mieux fait d'écouter mon père
mon père avait raison
bien mal acquis ne profite jamais ce
genre de choses qu'on se dit dans chez
janney l'impression d'avoir mal acquis
et vous êtes jamais dit mon père avait
raison
non finalement sa vie à lui qui est
humble qui est une vie simple et humble
finalement j'aurais été plus heureux si
j'avais accepté cette villa non mais
attendez je vais vous expliquer quelque
chose
il a été très heureux avec maman bref
qui depuis 60 ans et sa femme où on a
fêté ensemble 190 m oui mais vous visez
pas attendre si vous avez suivi ça rires
oui moi ça fait 28 ans que je suis avec
la mienne je suis aussi heureux que lui
avec la sienne malgré le parcours très
différents or comme mon bonheur conjugal
compte autant que lui et que ma vie
perdre professionnel compte après et que
j'ai pas eu de rater de ce côté là je
suis très zen musique
non
et maintenant j'appelle d'abord mi temps
nous à
ça fait quatre semaines quatre semaines
qui plombe
de cette émission est face à lui ce soir
mais ce qu'on écoute parti pour changer
ce soit retirée si on parlait un peu de
cul
[Applaudissements]
il faut virer michael la bonne idée donc
c'est le profit corty c'est pas ça très
sympa
abbassi attend alors ce que je dois dire
aussi pour complètement dédouaner
michael sait que le look qu'il a c'est
pas qui se la pète
c'est moi qui lui demandent de
s'habiller comme ça je dis ça pour tous
les emails que j'ai d'ailleurs j'ai un
email de caroline qui me dit et qui vous
parle avouent et qui dit un authentique
génie se doit de résister aux caprices
du despotisme
même s'il est éclairée ça c'est moi
remettez anciennes lunettes mon frère
d'accord moi je dis non
voilà il y avait un lien qui dit que tes
cheveux de la semaine dernière était pas
terrible il était jaune façon urines de
chat de gouttière et alors il ya six
coin qui me dit que vous êtes veilleur
de nuit dans un hôtel et silva me dis
que c'est pas dans domicile conjugal
qu'antoine doinel et veilleur de nuit
mais c'est dans baisers volés il dit y
aller fumer je réponds non pas ce soir
là voilà alors maintenant nous sommes là
une test spécial mauvais garçons en
hommage à cortix merci les sens commun
avec bernard tapie c'est d'être un
mauvais garçon la politique l'a dit la
politique du pire la différence est
qu'allègre vous tolère sur le bureau sur
le plateau ces pressions des biens dans
vous êtes prétention là c'est très très
chaud donc je rappelle l'enjeu
michael a battu tout le monde depuis
quatre semaines s'il gagne ce soit il
revient la semaine prochaine et cissé
corti qui gagne ça peut être quelqu'un
d'autre aussi bien sur la personne qui
n'est pas juste c'est pas marrant les
uns d'autres six personnes contrairement
à la wii c'est ça mon gars dont le
mandat demanda à l'anssi aura combien
d'équipés il avait contre lui à sydney
avant d'arriver en personne contre toi
tu n'as plus qu'une
déjà là des scores non je rappelle je
rappelle donc il s'agit du blind thèse
mauvais garçon tout le monde est prêt et
donc le on va voir tout de suite si
didier veut bien envoyé la première
musique c'est vous me dire l'intervalle
joe dassin bien
c'est pire que kader matin
non parce que calais olivier linda hardy
leurs filets les réponses je suis sûr
que ma femme les a pas fait d accord ça
c'est clair
est-ce qu'on va maintenant re mais juge
que déploie s'appelle brigitte
ah ça vous avez reconnu
c'est son métier les saltimbanques
adapte à gaza attention là c'est très
très sérieux je sens là donc qu'est ce
qui est écrit sur cette ardoise parce
que je suis partagé les points d'accord
approche toi ameline parce que si tu
veux partie pendant dix ans avant tu
disais corti le score est là non mais il
n'arrive plus à suivre
il me montre les pensionnats alosi
chanson numéro 2 la boîte en biologie
corti 2
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui mon papa à moi c'est un gangster
c'est un peu ce que pourrait dire votre
fils d'une certaine façon oui domtar oui
docteur stomy bugzy donc
ah oui c'est là je suis désolé c'est un
peu largué klaus et en même temps est en
même temps là on atteint des sommets la
suivre l'élève sait j'avais vu à la
première note ils reconnaissent qu'ils
michael perce un drap un drame il vous
rendez pas compte
bon tout le monde est bien concentré
sahara six corps tigane c'est aussi un
drame c'est gentil mais c'est aussi un
art parlement il a marqué deux points
attention sans son numéro 3
moi je suis désolé il ya là vraiment
c'est parce que la bonne façon de vivre
c'était effectivement gantin petite
faiblesse ni cup c'était corti la bonne
façon de vie amicale
attention va voir on n'est qu'à la
chanson numéro trois chansons numéro 4
didier dutronc
tél
y aller avec elle était mise éducation
nationale mais là il n'avait jamais vu
ça n'en répare en est ainsi dans la vie
c'est pas mal lu c'est celui qu'à malte
wire je vais le voulait transmettre un
message c et disais que c'est dommage
qu'il soit parti à hawija vos parents
faute des parents penser que c'est
dommage que ça va beaucoup de profs ça
aussi de la preuve de mes enfants il dit
c'est ouais bah oui oui
maintenant il va se lancer dans
l'adaptation de la terre de nouveaux
champs son numéro 5
obligé d'y aménager dean elvis si bons
moments sont maintenant en amidon on a
mis au point un système de filmage qui
fait serge chanson numéro 5
josiane et la corse sont sortis après en
pop up mai
ok j'ai dit attention et usant les
garçons sont son numéro 6 d'assen la
bande à volonté c'est son boulot quand
ils font des signes il veut tenir et
comme une merde non c'est pas moi c'est
là c'est la vie réelle je vais pas vrai
du tout ses salades et les lichens les
emails en me disant que j'ai tout fait
pour virer michael c'est pas vrai les
chansons sont choisis les corti corti
battant perdre contre corti c'est comme
perdre contre la nba est d'accord ok
mais là j'ai pas besoin d'y croire
là tu seras médaille d'argent à vos
chansons numéro 7
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beauchamp annonçait non se perdre dans
ça compte pas il a mis la révélation a
répondu ouais c'est bien je didier ton
chèque est à la compta bon ce point
marche pas chanson numéro 8
mais peur du plaisancier johnny hallyday
la femip ancien quartier
[Musique]
chanson numéro nappe je veux
l'interprète
[Musique]
à l'honneur regardez ça chauffe dans les
ardeurs
chanson numéro 10
gazeau vague william klein
exact en brigitte bardot et serge
gainsbourg
catherine quel est le score 6 2 ben
philippe ravaux fils est sorti à gagner
la nuit
racing ou non
alors que les cours des chiottes et la
scène des chances qu'on voit milan fait
leur fasse
oui mon prochain oui moi je suis mariée
alors good très bien
alors tout le monde connaît ça
l'album s'appelait au nom de la lune et
on gounon a vendu dans le monde entier 5
millions d'exemplaires et
oui je savais pas alors aujourd'hui à ça
[Musique]
c'est tout ce que j'espère toujours
espérer j'espère bonjour
m
saluons gap ce chien masse mais si mais
si m
les autorités
ouah
mais c'est tout
m
qu'est ce qui se voit comme toi tout
mais simplement car en donner j'ai envie
je dois faire la mission de boules à moi
j'ai envie de m'asseoir l'a fait le tour
il n'y a pas de souci suivront plus fort
qu'il en est dans un bar
ça maintient ses taux à dix ans et c'est
pas dur ça c'est pas lui qui sont ils
il est d'ailleurs plus compte
les plus grosses images interviews en
boule en voulons voir venir ce beau
succès discographique
mais d'abord on va raconter un petit peu
votre histoire qui est une histoire pas
banale du tout d'éteindre les hyènes
c'est joli c'est gentil ça vous a plu
anggun 6 pts à sa semi type tu
assassines et ça veut dire la grâce qui
se créent dans un rêve
[Musique]
c'est ça c'est lourd à porter et thierry
indices en six ans dix ans si dans dix
ans si ça vient du latin art douce ce
nous qui veut dire la grande gueule art
douce fort ce nous la voix la grande
gueule
c'est un petit peu dur à porter comme
prénom là quand vous appelez la grâce
qui se créent dans un rêve évidemment
que vous êtes petit c'est un peu
emmerdant c'est une idée de votre père
votre père était écrivain poète
journaliste peintre à 7
les fans des beatles entre autres c'est
vrai vous saviez chanter quand vous
étiez petit toutes les chansons des
beatles
oui parce qu'il y avait des chansons
indonésienne que j'ai pas le droit
d'écouter donc mon père voulait que
j'écoutais les quelle est votre chanson
des beatles préféré en bonne voie je
suis un fan des beatles absolue je veux
que ça tu veux vous que vous voyez le
terme en mai dans les midlands était
bien à ça vous plaît cela
m
bonjour votre père vous a appris à
chanter
et quand vous étiez petite île vous
écrivait des chansons mais votre père a
toujours fui la célébrité et pourtant
c'est quelqu'un de toit très fort mais
il n'a jamais voulu être
il n'aime pas être possédées par quelque
chose la célébrité c'est quelque chose
qui vous possédez rien voilà c'est un
esprit libre
oui et d'ailleurs ils possèdent rien du
tout ils achètent une saisie sur votre
cas où il marchait toujours pieds nus
voilà un voile a par exemple fait d'une
famille d'artistes votre grand-père et
des danseurs dans un palais dans le
centre de java
votre mère était issu de la noblesse de
wendel et non en indonésie ce qu'il faut
expliquer vos amis téléspectateurs c'est
que tout le monde sait chanter quand on
est bébé on apprend à marcher on apprend
à parler on apprend à danser on apprend
à chanter c'est fait partie de la
culture normal indonésie c'est ça mais
vous connaissez tous je vais tout
d'abord parce que j'adore l'indonésie à
bas les gens croient préféré sur la
terre c'est vrai j'étais avalé trop
semaines dans le camp gones quand vous
êtes petit vous étudié le piano la danse
balinaise
un effet relais comme ça fait voir
comment on fait j'ai oublié
[Applaudissements]
voilà vous êtes sur scène à l'âge de 7
ans premier disque à 9 ans à 12 ans elle
fait un album de rock et vous donnez une
star en asie du sud est
tournée en asie du sud est à l'âge de 13
ans et ça alors vous rêvez à l'époque de
l'adolescence devenir la première
chanteuse de heavy metal grande idée
vous étiez fan de metallica c'est ça et
j'ai ouï agadez et vous connaissez mes
gars mais je connais c'est bien mais
c'était bien bien 18 ans donnait marbre
ça va devenir une vraie femme vous jetez
les doc martin 1
vous mettez des souliers fin oui et
alors là comme quoi un jour anggun et en
tournée à bornéo et elle rencontre un
français c'est fois c'est incroyable un
coin la france la france des français
quand même vous tous vous tomber
amoureuse de lui
et alors vous rencontrer à bornéo et je
vous revoyez à singapour vous marier
malgré les réticences de votre famille
[Rires]
est alors bon votre famille vous avez
vous quitté l'indonésie vous allez à
londres d'abord en 94 et finalement ça
vous plaît pas tellement londres vous
venez à paris oui vous né à paris et
vous adorez paris
et quand vous arrivez à paris vous dites
je veux vivre là c'est l'endroit qui
vous plaît paris on connaissait quad
taille à par jordi vous connaissiez quoi
de la france c'est vrai gouin
connaissait jordi mais c'était le
terrain toute la longueur exactement wii
qui a fait le tour du monde donc désolé
parce que vous avez la france l'image de
la france
vous apprenez vous allez prendre en 96
des cours à l'alliance française et
alors là ça c'est incroyable
à quoi ça tient la vie regardez le frère
de votre voisin le faire de votre voisin
connaît un électricien qui avait rendu
service à florent pagny et florent pagny
bas ils vous présentent erick benzi et
voilà et ça a donné ça
ces fleurs a prévenu sa non sert aux
gones avant et nous on croit que la vie
de chanteuse comme ça à succès tout
c'est la bonne vie et pas du tout parce
que quand on boude raconte sa vie elle
dit c'est terrible parce qu'on voit dans
la journée des milliers de gens qui vous
adule qui applaudissent des cons
apparaît et le soir on se retrouve tout
seul dans sa chambre d'hôtel en train de
penser à son homme c'est vrai oui de la
tournée on est face à des solitudes qui
ont choisi par la tournelle d'être
malheureuse des fois tout seul comme ça
oui parce que enfin je suis indonésienne
j'ai pas l'habitude d'être seul est ce
que vous savez on good qu'on ne bouge
pas par le jingle oui parce que je sais
que votre management vous l'a dit mon
management maison de disques nous a dit
me bouge pas bien je vous ai vite et à
la hong lei des gens qui ont bougé alors
vous avez pas bougé vais me regarde et
on ne bouge pas on le dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les trieuses j'adore j'adore les filles
qui sont les mieux notés a ou croyances
si vous croyez en dieu
ouais mais musulmane au départ au départ
vous envoyons une école catholique c'est
ça c'est ça pour vous ouvrir sur le
monde
oui pour savoir que pastore en bas une
vérité vous dites on dit toujours un
dieu pourquoi on dit pas une dieu c'est
vrai j'avais jamais entendue celle-là
pourquoi pas parce que mots ça c'est à
voir avec la langue française il ya le
féminin et masculin
c'est vrai qu'on dit toujours un dieu
c'est moi pocus est pas pareil je sais
dieu quand même on dit pas un chêne non
plus non si jane birkin ça fait trente
ans qu'elle est en france je dis
toujours je vais aller vers le coach et
m'asseoir sur le chaise
bon le fait au top un exploit même temps
où est ce que vous croyez aux anges
gardiens oui ah bon est ce que vous
croyez aux extraterrestres je crois
qu'on n'est pas seul j'ai envie croire
ouvriers aux mauvais esprits
oui y'en a il y en a des mauvais esprits
des fois ce soir il n'a pas
non j'ai des mauvaises esprit là non non
à la non pas la vérité anggun vous êtes
la première un deuxième qui voient non
vie vous regarde
j'ai déjà vu est ce que vous croyez aux
fantômes
à quand on croit aux anges en inventant
mais je préfère pas quoi le sorcier
je les ai déjà vus
est ce que vous croyez à l'amour
toujours j'ai envie croire vous voyez
superman
la tour montparnasse la ferme kouassi
akon juillet
et
eric et ramzy bonsoir syrien la rio pour
vous saluer donc on va faire un peu de
promo on y va on y va donc en commun
s'arrête au nom d'abord on fait là on
fait la tournée d'abord un pardon la
tournée la tournée 2010 exact 1 qui
s'est terminé par un passage à l'olympia
à de l'année dernier de l'année dernière
oui oui mais c'est de la vieille promo
il s'est dit serein tout le monde est au
courant comme patois est aujourd'hui un
film away
alors c'est comment on fait un
c
bien dit son président je viens à
l'ordre du jour d'un film qui est
produit par christian fechner réalisé
par charles nemes qui faisait h qui
faisait des villages sur quatre bus qui
a fait avant aussi les héros n'ont pas
froid aux oreilles de godzilla jurassic
park mais s'est dit faire aussi un très
bon poulet est aussi le voulait mais
metz alors le pitch vous le faites
ouais mais l'histoire l'histoire du film
de quoi ça parle
le pitch j'ai envie de dire des trucs
bien et tous et dieu sait qu'il faudrait
répondre parce que c'est la promo et
tout mais j'ai ensuite mme par ailleurs
un peu de promo pour faire le pauvre 20
millions d'euros dont 10 millions pour
le film
c'est génial
docteur à nourrir quand même à mourir à
mourir dont je vais le faire alors si
vous êtes laveur de carreaux à c'est un
honneur mais je fais le pitch vous êtes
à bord de cars au tour montparnasse
l'instant c'est exact et puis vous voyez
comme ça vous êtes sur votre nacelle
mais faut le faire un peu mieux ouais
parce que sur votre nez s'est éveillée
stéphanie quai en fête marina mais bon
dans le film s'appelle stéphanie octobre
c'est un fils bon et dont vous êtes
extrêmement bas vous êtes a vendu 7 ckoi
c'est comme un film
ouais pareil c'est un peu comme un fou
avec des explosions mais enfin quoi et
alors vous plaît un moment là des
figurants allez on y va
moi sur cette glande amoureux de
stéphanie wii dont je suis amoureux dans
le film ouais et qui soudainement est
prise en otage pourquoi parce qu'un
conseil d'administration un conseil
d'animation très très puissant mais très
puissante et lens va le groupement rival
au début on veut on voulait les appelait
les deux furent sac et est un bon
apparemment la marque a refusé coller de
son image à nous il trouvait que c'était
pas assez classe alors surtout de
montech de fursac c'est super classe
[Musique]
et bah alors 52 francs la place mais là
je crois que c'est la meilleure promo
c'est ce soir à je te jure c'est
vraiment de la john promo je me connais
je te jure que oui atterrir dit ça mais
c'est bien c'est vraiment fort en promo
les mecs
queyranne si vous êtes les clients ideo
pour une nouvelle interview
il s'appelle l'interview sans intérêt
sans intérêt
mais j'adore cette musique aussi
vivement le genre ne pas bouger et tu
mets une musique qui fait bouger ben moi
c'est ça c'est pour ça que c'est
difficile bien sûr qu'aujourd'hui on
verra bien alors intervenu sans intérêt
voici comment ça va comme lundi réponse
sans intérêt ah oui c'est la nuit sans
intérêt comment ça va tuyau de poêle
tu vois ce à quoi la à mercredi prochain
mercredi 28
je pense et j'espère que la prochaine
question j'aurais de la répartie ma
rentrée c'est pas possible parce que
c'est une interview sans intérêt j'étais
dit sa vérité tu vois la mer t'as pas
trop chaud là non j'ai mis un pull pour
faire style je suis branché mais free
j'ai chaud quand même vous faites quoi
pour les vacances normalement pour
l'instant rien n'est prévu
réponse les enterrer sa mère soit bien
comprise et tu vas quand on s'en fout
moi de mes vacances
ouais je n'ai revu lundi alors avec bien
franchement bien ses réponses sans
intéresser ceux qui sont moins chers
sont dangereux tout au sérieux mais oui
monsieur nous avons vu ceci est là pour
vous et depuis quand il n'a pas plu
comme ça il n'a pas plu ouais comme ça
depuis ça fait bien là d'un vrai qu'il a
pu sept ans c'est 140 de voter dimanche
ouais on s'est bien passé vraiment de là
nous et je m'entends c'est dingue ben
ouais franchement si surprenant après 24
ans quoi je préfère la mer ou l'océan
on perd des spectateurs moi mais si on
me dira parce que sinon moi je peux
balancer des trucs et du cul dedans
que m q dans ma phrase de ma réponse est
tombée vas-y tu devrais faire l'amère du
cul je sais c'est pour choper l'audience
elle te rappeler non mais j'attends
normalement enfin parce que j'avais pas
débranché mon téléphone
là je vais le brancher après et
peut-être qu'elle va rappeler mais si
elle laisse un message je vais aller à
fond dans ton truc mais si elle laisse
un message je sais pas si je le
rappellerai parce que très honnêtement
redonner ton numéro un
j'ai donné mon numéro et raisonnée
lequel servait au pas le coup qu'elle
radars elle parce que de toute manière
on sait quoi ouais tu es avec moi mais
tu y crois toi ce truc absolument à tous
tout ce que vous dites monsieur je vous
crois hélas une question sans intérêt
mais que pas de moi
elle est née d'un intérêt man et vous
aimez les chiens j'adore ça génial
un chien c'est des poils c'est ce n'est
pas de céder yeux sa course a redit
faisait tellement de fermer le gaz avant
de partir j'ai pas de gaz tout et tout
et au laser chez moi
m
très bien pour l'interview sans intérêt
j'adore bien je dansais question bidon
ça va être bon on en a fait plein des
émissions donc sa piste qui mène à la
différence c'est qu'ici on le fait
exprès de faire des questions sans
intérêt et pourtant je n'y pensais pas
exprès voilà oui
magnéto si bien alors maintenant me
sauver ce point fr laurent non ben si on
va vendre de la camelote alors vous
savez comment on fait des enfants
attention les petites mains vous savez
ce qu'il faut faire
moi j'ai répété un alors fait voir
attention un deux trois tu le fais pas
toi cavanna c'est formidable de le
public est entraîné ce luxe avant et
quand même
attention qu'est ce qu'il faut faire il
faut comme striée nothing ampoules
l'applaudissement chez les sourds muets
n'hésite pas à vous méprisez des
formules n'ont pas tout à fait par une
variante moi je fais des moulinets en
même temps nous permettrait d'être
indiscipliné comme je le suis dans
d'autres enceintes infernale
j'ai approuvé la rebelle c'est un punk
bon il a publié un livre
elle
[Applaudissements]
je signale arnaud de montebourg arnaud
montebourg que même les maîtres du monde
le font donc la prochaine foire nos
efforts elle pourra le faire voilà parce
que quand même là on a vu qu'un maître
du monde le fait alors c'est comment
faire
marveaux c'est que même l'archevêque de
paris l'a fait quand même temps mais
même le pape chez lui quand il fait beau
il ay la dz un des gens qui
l'api qui est le mien
après marie gillain encore une belle
joie si christine okrent intel à
messieurs
christine bonsoir donc vous publiez un
livre qui s'appelle vous c'est comment
on fait christine un gvt g de le faire
mais voilà vos cervelles va sur la photo
là du coup non il suffit de regarder
d'autres côté mieux la double vie de
kevin maintenant d'hillary clinton
attention ça
on compterait rencontré au début des
années 70 donc ça veut dire que vous
êtes quand même bien placé pour en
parler parce que ça fait un moment où
vous la connaissez la même coupe de
cheveux alors ah bah non leur écoute et
regarde non regardez moi j'ai la même
depuis des années on sait qu'il arrive
c'est là c'est ça qui nous a conviés à
changer le plus de coiffure la femme
publique dans lé christine way est vrai
quand on lit de buka il ya un côté auto
portrait de cassino cra allons quand
même
bah oui c'est évident d'abord vous êtes
mariés tous ces deux âmes est président
mais vous vous êtes dit choix avec
kouchner vous êtes mariés ou compagnes
concubin ok ben concubin maman
contemporain
non ça fait un peu comme un mariage un
bond de la l'enfant sera annoncée il ya
une énorme différence avant on veut pas
divorcer
oui c'est vrai mérite qu'on y
réfléchisse on va vous est toutes les
deux avec un homme politique est un
séducteur parce que kouchner aussi
séducteur moi vous avez sens commun vous
les aimez beau par mam
bin c'est autre chose ouais vous les
aimez vous voulez vous les aimez vous
aimez chez vous aimez tous les deux
votre votre homme vous avez un seul
enfant et toutes les deux très diplômé
vous avez des carrières brillantes que
vous avez réalisé sans votre époux l'une
et l'autre dans mon cas mais tendant
tient pas quand même et c'est une
avocate hillary clinton comme une
avocate après devient la femme de bill
moi j'ai cette grande erreur de vouloir
faire les choses tout seul est une
chanson comme ça faisait gagner de
l'argent tout les deux donc sans vos
maris vous êtes puis rentre plus
brillantes ambitieuse plus classement
vous avez plein plein de points communs
j'espère que c'est un compliment j'en
suis pas tout à fait sûr ah bon vous
êtes une clé 2d
bien c'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant
eh bien vous êtes d'une famille quand
même faut le dire de la haute
bourgeoisie non tomber c'est pas un
reproche à et non mais c'est pas celle
ci dessous c'est faux je vais dire non
bourgeoisie oui mérite méritante
votre père était directeur de cabinet de
ce pacte a été le grand artisan belge de
la construction européenne
si vous connaissez ce pack non chez eux
c'était
ça c'était celle et gilles a bien failli
quand on repense je regarde l'émission
oui monsieur gilles après vous enroulez
ainsi voulait pas du tout à mon faire sa
vie ne fume pas pas de cabanes et siaka
bannissez les gibbons maman oui mais pas
pas comment il fait très motivant alors
oui excusez moi christine j'ai appris un
truc vos parents ont divorcé
oui mais après tant d'années mais je
veux pas en parler parce que toulouse
est tout le village a un enfant dans la
jungle
bah oui après vingt ans ça se fête
n'était pas au courant
et oui voilà bon enfin on ne
s'appesantit pas là dessus parce que
vous connaissez la discrétion des
caractères dans cette émission on n'a
toujours pas de nom breux du signal
quand même et on est presque au bout
bien alors vous arrivez à paris à l'âge
de 6 ans votre père est nommé
ambassadeur c'est ça je ne connais ses
vignes et alors là attention à la il
faut placer bien collège sévigné ensuite
fait sciences po est alors imaginer que
si nos craintes à sciences po petit
tailleur en tweed petit shetland à moi
je vois très bien petit shetland petite
mini cooper blank absolument avec un
filet noir un filet noir dessus voilà
sièges noirs
équitation mademoiselle aux craintes à
l'époque que préfère brel aux beatles
quand même elle lit les bouddhistes
messiba brel tout le monde c'est quand
même moi l'époque je préférais comme les
beatles ça vous lisez les mémoires
d'hadrien de marguerite yourcenar
seulement excellente ou bonne dizaine à
tous les jeunes gens pas de nouveau
roman pas trop heureux y est jamais trop
compris voilà
et vous avez le culot de dire et ça
c'est énorme je n'étais pas conformiste
sms que cech roger meece a dit ça après
tout et d'écriture des deux petits
shetland et de la mini cooper ou 18
n'était pas conforme bien c'est
peut-être juste une nouvelle apparence
aussi
vous n'étiez pas conformiste comme on
vient de le voir vous sortez major de
sciences po quand même pas mal en fin de
votre section vous allez à cambridge
quand même il a évidemment vous trouver
un petit job assez eux mais ça c'est par
piston un an j'ai fait mon troisième
cycle de sciences politiques menace il a
fait l'ena a bon goût mais c'est bon ça
tombe bien
deuxième information c'est vrai ce que
je dis non il était quand même top bcbg
que c'est notre année
donc là vous rentrez chez nbc faut dire
vous avez commencé quand même au bas de
l'échelle vous étiez grouillot on peut
dire insolent chauliac brouillonne
guyotte c'est que christine aller hors
ligne à dédouaner les cassettes aller à
l'époque dissident transgreen est dans
des boîtes en fer comprenez dans les
salles voilà l aléa or l'iran pendant 68
vous avez dit d'ailleurs pendant que les
autres quitter les classes moi je
faisais mes classes et puis après de fil
en aiguille quand même parce que cette
ambitieuse ce parent proche de basse à
vous bossez vous devenez réalisatrice
journalistes et vous partez aux usa chez
cbs et là vous participé pendant six ans
1,6 team elite ce qu'est le grand
magazine d'information américain dni
combien de temps entre entre orly et
sexy munich
j'ai fait ça un an et demi rien ans et
demi c'est bien ensuite bon vous passer
six ans la barre ils vont commencer à
renouer avec la france à travers un
magazine qui s'appelait vendredi sur
france 3 vous amorcez votre retour en
france
alors après 80 vous arrivez au journal
télévisé de france 2 enfin d'antenne 2 à
l'époque en alternance avec ppda
mais après tout seul quand ppda est
parti boucher rester jusqu'à 85 et alors
là je vois comment vous êtes arrivé à ce
journal vous êtes je vous reproche pas
mais vous êtes vraiment ambitieuse à les
mecs alors eux ils sont là ils placent
prendre tous les samedis il faut une
audience maximale
il veut faire le 21 il fait partie de
ceux qui n'ont pas tout de suite faire
le va pas toucher 15 040 peut-être moins
pas tout de suite
voilà élan après dès qu'ils voient femme
qu'il faut faire c'est l'été 80 des
groupes est en vacances antibes vous
chercher son numéro dans l'annuaire
vous le trouvez vous l'appelez au flanc
vite voilà je veux présenter le 21 pas
du tout pourquoi vous lui donne encore
plus drôle sur les faces malaisie alors
j'appelle des gros j'ai une grande
admiration pour les groupes 5 colonnes
etc
j'en avais marre de me lever à 3h15 du
matin pour faire le journal de 8h sur
hot c'est vraiment très riche combine
bref j'appelle des gros que juni voilà
monsieur cetera il me dit ah c'est vous
il me dit j'aime pas votre voix donc
c'était déjà un bon début
et puis m'a donné rendez vous à paris et
alors bourgon vous est peut-être venue
des groupes qui était un merveilleux
vieux monsieur qui avait un très très
mauvais caractère ce qui fait qu'il a
été à chaque fois vidés par les hommes
politiques pardon qui ne supportait pas
son indépendance d'esprit celui est
arrivé plusieurs fois dans la vie et
donc il me reçoit il vient d'être nommé
président d'antenne 2 avril à 7 clope au
bec qui me regardent ils ronchonnent ne
parle pas
qu'est ce que je pourrais bien lui faire
faire et moi je pensais franchement pas
au 20 heures
moi j'arrivais en gros du grand
reportage et j'avais jamais ce que vous
pensez pas au 20 heures mais on n'est
pas du tout s'est rendu tout mon monde
mon truc moi je voulais faire un
magazine il faut faire du reportage cet
été vous allez offrir
exemple est dit un bel 20 heures tu vois
le vote et là ça a été énorme
vous étiez la première femme à présenter
le 20h je vais ramasser le ramassage pas
combien de sept d'or d'honneur là
c'était la reine christine c'est
l'époque de la reine christine savait
qu'en france on coupe les têtes
après les règnes oui je suis bien placé
pour savoir pauvre marie antoinette tu
nous regardes je suis mon sens oui vous
avez touché juste donc là vous partez à
tf1 pour 240 mille francs par mois
oui ce qu'était par rapport à d'autres
et vous en serez rapidement au conflit
et patrick le lay comme ça comme
beaucoup dans jusque là rien d'étonnant
en 88
vous revenez sur france 2 et la scandale
parce que vous baissez votre salaire de
moitié à celle de 240 passer à 120 alors
même mois et une cabale qu'est lancé par
paul amar et qui dit moi je prends ça
mois de congé si elle gagne 120 mille
balles par mois je pense à moi de congé
est donc une grève
certains étaient relativement soulagés
l'idée qu'il s'en aille c'est vrai bien
hélas non là je rigole pas parce que
vous avez vraiment souffert je pense
sérieusement vous rentriez dans un
restaurant les gens disaient avec quoi
elle l'a payé son manteau avec l'argent
des contribuables vous aviez
l'impression d'être tondus en 44 non
c'était assez pénible
ouais c'était assez pénible de large est
malade vous êtes ne me ni perfusion
assistance respiratoire
il ya même un journal qui écrit à
l'époque c'est pas vrai elle n'est pas
l'hôpital tout ça c'est bidon vous savez
à quel point les journalistes peuvent
être méchants
non mais c'est pas honnêtement vous avez
j'imagine année bavella ouais mais moi
je vais vous dire un truc le plus
choquant pour moi dans toute cette
affaire c'est pas un serial tout ça
jusqu'au veille d'hab on vous est
expliqué antenne 2 l'histoire du salaire
les gens gagnent tellement plus
aujourd'hui
moi ce que je trouve de plus choquant
dans toute votre carrière c'est le 12
avril 92 vous interviewez françois
mitterrand avec un 2 5 p r et là on voit
une chose absolument extraordinaire que
j'aurais jamais pensé voir de ma vie
c'est à dire un président de la
république est interviewé par deux
femmes de ministres ou s'agit en partie
exact nous faisions partie d'un groupe
de six journalistes week avait été
choisie comme d'habitude à l'époque par
le regretté jacques billand il y avait
des représentants de chaque chaîne
il y avait entre autres un ancien mari
d'anne sinclair vivent en famille là on
était cette voie là et personne comme je
crois qu'on s'y bierne que moi avions
quelques qualités qualités
professionnelles de la pensée il a fallu
un académicien par ailleurs tout à fait
charmant efforts admirateurs de
l'artiste car les compliments monde
derrière il va morfler qu'est ce qu'il a
dit dans le sens et il a fait un papier
en disant mais comment un président qui
se fait interner
il a un peu heureusement d'état peut
tomber dans les vous n'aurez que sino
cam seulement vous ne mangez pas pensé
second je vais ouvrir pour plein de
raisons mais d'abord moi j'ai toujours
fait mon parcours professionnel
seul oui j'ai eu l'immense bonheur de
rencontrer bernard assez tard dans ma
vie enfin le tard à mon goût et donc
beaucoup plus tard et il était vraiment
avoir la politesse à médecins sans
frontières et médecins du monde donc
voilà on nettoiera vrai que ça fait
bizarre
vous êtes devant votre télé où il
présenta public intervient par deux
femmes de ministres mais vous n'avez pas
l'étiquette fin 2006 vous êtes vous êtes
quelqu'un en l'occurence moi qui a
présenté des centaines 20 journaux
télévisés est-ce qu'on peut être aussi
impertinents avec un président un public
quand on a son mot à dire
les tessinois pertinente en tout cas
suffisamment précises dans quelques
questions à l'époque je me souviens sur
quelques amitiés qu'il pouvait avoir
pour que le président très sèchement
n'ai plus envie de me parler
donc je ne crois bien d'ailleurs enfin
bien alors
d'ailleurs bernard kouchner vous êtes
d'accord avec ça dans la touche n'est
pas en odeur à l'elysée bernard kouchner
a signé en 1976
l'appel du 18 juin pour légaliser la
marijuana maintenant qu'il au ministère
de la santé vous croyez qu'il va aider
mais il a déjà fait beaucoup il a mis en
place il a fait nommer madame maestracci
si ma mémoire est bonne et il est il
essaie de faire évoluer les mentalités
sur un sujet qui en france par
comparaison avec ce qui se passe dans
d'autres volumes européens
jésus de crispation et d'hypocrites et
la mentalité qu'il faut faire évoluer
ses les gouvernants parce que les
mentalités mentalité des français les
mentalités des gouvernants d'accord et
ce qu'ils croient être les réactions de
leurs électeurs qu'on est dans un noeud
de choses d'une chose j'aime pas quand
dans vos émissions vous poser la
question sur le cabanis
m
bien alors attention maintenant on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle
une
oui
est ce qu'on préférait draguer vous
faire draguer tu préfères draguer
préféré embrasser ou faire embrasser ans
ça dépend qui ouais c'est la joie coin
préféré caresser vous faire caresser les
concepts question je suis désolé ce
n'est pas le dire alors l homme va pas
sans l'autre
quel est le lieu idéal pour une étreinte
n'importe bonnes réponses que sinon
qu'elle est le lieu où vous êtes
incapable de faire l'amour en revanche
dans un ascenseur pourquoi les immeubles
sont passés au en france
je vous ai besoin d'aimer pour faire
l'amour ou de faire l'amour pourrait
mais j'ai besoin des briques souvent les
filles fait la différence entre les
filles et les garçons
est ce que vous préférez ah oui un mec
qui bosse bien mecha infidèles ou un mec
qui passe mal mais que fidèle préfère ne
pas avoir à essayer enfin vérifier si
c'est compliqué comme question oui oui
enfin c'est aussi con si je peux me
permettre
c'est pas la balle est allée du mail
vous permet à vous tombe dessus
bah oui c'est l'interview belges ont
préféré un mec qui fait moins que vous
le faire oui ça m'a fait revivre
oui reste élevé mais une fois on peut
aussi parler comme ça vous m'excusez
mais plutôt de bruxelles ah oui moi
j'adore ah je croyais qu avec vous je
suis ravi ah ouais ça fait des soirées
couronnement faut peu finalement
ah oui dans le coup vous vous pensez
qu'il faut pas savoir où tout se dire je
vois qu'il ya des choses qu'il faut se
dire des choses qui ne font pas ça
d'accord mais très bien est-ce que vous
avez des fantasmes non encore réalisés
bien sûr à bord et vous
1 je dirai pas lesquels je vous demande
pas avec elle mais maintenant j'essaye
de précéder vous voulez vous voulez
réaliser vous savez dans l'idée de vous
avez vous acharnez avait réalisé il ya
des idées comme ça qu'il ya encore des
trucs à faire quoi c'est à dire plein
merci
c'est si le tram la double vie du
véhicule
chez robert laffont
j'ai souvent
alors nous allons faire ce soir un blind
test spécial pluie inutile d'expliquer
pourquoi
mais pour arbitrer le blind test
j'appelle mention philippe bordier
[Applaudissements]
voilà
danseur
bien attention spéciale cuir aujourd'hui
on va jouer avec les ombres est
évidemment très sombre et le chinois la
re bonsoir
alors je représente delphine ici en
blanc oui et puis la jolie nadia aussi
un endroit très bien donc on joue les
couleurs contre le blanc d'accord donc
c'est spécial puis vous connaissez le
principe vous me donnez l'interprète
évidemment pas du tout le titre de la
chanson uniquement l'interprète delà de
la crise
c
fastoche away sein du gie le plus facile
du moins chez les gorges et d'esther moi
justement baril s'est toujours attention
didier
[Musique]
chacun sa sévère pendant mes jours
la ville d'al baïda
je sais moi
bien ça fait un partout donc merci c'est
un projet d'accord qui ont marqué les
points on continue didier
frings prix pour broadway
je demande un replay je veux revoir ça
je veux ressentir moment un écho à la
pied du premier accord et reconnaît prix
serge khalfon s'il vous plaît ripley
dans l'iran continue didier
attention regardez le regard des us plus
[Musique]
bien alors l'interprète
oui oui d'interprète
tél
soir
des musiques de votre époque ça c'est
encore pire ce qui arrive la vidéo
interview à tradingsat com
oh
et oui j'en sois numéro six loups garous
ou gamma me garde bien
au lycée
excellent ce soir dernier céline est
dédié
[Musique]
là
borloo
c'est un robot je décris post il dit je
décline touristes le collectif
fonctionnera battant samedi à aimé
jacquet
à défaut
alors c'est fort ça ici et il me dit
viens on aimait les chansons et les
écrits l'habitude d'être ouvert alors la
suite
jeux d'habilité foot avec ce prix 24/10
dieu le sous marin
6 3 1 à 10 ans chez arthur 20 ans devant
gulli bien maintenant il ya le super
bowl c'est la règle du jeu ce qui se
trouve le super banco gagne tout même si
l'on en croit que c'est injuste mais
superbe on connaît attends attends
m
[Musique]
les forêts
etc
[Musique]
1 2 1 2 1 bravo nous appeler comment
filmer mais c'est qui l'éruption
[Musique]
nous allons travailler
de la chance que vous avez deux soirs
entre air avec le superbe anthony west
nile
non
m
[Musique]
il m
non
e
[Musique]
oui
non
l'eau